coming to you in five
four three two
come on man welcome back to the a3
podcast we got a new president
who goes come on man
now that joe biden welcome to after dark
everybody thank you for
waiting graciously for me i was making a
bomb tick-tock
so we're starting to have like in crew
drama
everyone's upset at ethan it's only his
fault
blame
[Music]
it helps the show a lot like i made this
bomb ass tick tock you guys should go
look at it
i'm afraid to post it because it has
copyrighted music but ethan thank you
keemstar
keemstar thinks i'm doing the right
thing right keemstar
come on it's worth it to be 10 minutes
lucky okay he's
kind of stuck on a loop there
thank you for joining us everybody all
jews all
jews all jews are great
good luck all jews thank you
this episode is brought to you by hbo
max we love it
coming up in the world we love hbo max i
love hbo
all right this isn't part of the plug i
genuinely love hbo
is great and they almost don't even need
to pay us for this problem i love it
they almost never miss no yeah they make
the best of
yeah anyway um
listen we've got a we've got a big show
here i mean we've got so much to talk
about
we've got great call-ins we've got great
i have to touch on the trisha drama with
shane and
jeffrey and all this because a lot of
has developed you know
i've got all the q on meltdown from the
biden administration because
it's guys it's hard to believe like that
a collective
a collective psychosis has taken over an
entire population of the country where
they
actually believe q anon was real
and there was probably a million people
expecting
literally expecting at joe biden's
inaugural
inauguration for the military to arrest
him
hillary clinton obama and all those guys
for running a secret pedophile ring and
then
instilling the military police and then
trump becoming president
people literally believe man
and so there's a lot of melting down as
people realize they were bamboozled by
whoever q was which i'm sure was just a
4chan troll who couldn't believe people
actually
taking him seriously
crazy so there's that also garth brooks
was at the inauguration
kissing he garth brooks is such an agent
of death
i'll show you guys what i mean but come
on actually let's just watch it
because this is a great one to start
garth brooks is an agent of death we've
known this about him
but now it's proven so he's up there
without a mask let the conversation
begin
and he's kissing the president the wives
ex-presidents he is up there
watch this garf with obama michelle
i like that
that's clinton hillary
give him a kiss why don't you oh and
then whoever that is yeah who else do
they not infect
give a kiss and every everyone gets
kisses garth
come on man do you not know about kovid
let the conversation begin
i think garth is a russian agent it's
like hey
um can you just put your mask on
tonight on the news it's like well he
was just singing come on
man he was just singing but that came
out with the mask you do the elbow
started with the mask but
you do the thing and then you put the
mask back on
okay later in the news tonight
breaking news also you don't really kiss
and during a pandemic actually that's
what i'm saying like elbow bump bro
no [ __ ] kissing dog god damn garf
i got friends in low places six feet
under the ground
i'm a russian agent that's his song
friends in all places that's like his
big song
i like that um but i truly think tonight
on the news
breaking news that the clinton and
obama's have all
fallen gravely ill by kovid
the fbi is investing garth brooks for
possible ties to the kremlin
i heard he wasn't that good i'm like
i just thought it wasn't that good you
know so you are hating
come on man am i hating i come on
interesting point
well what is the definition of hating
because maybe it's not like oh i'm a
hater it's just like yeah i just didn't
think it was that good
hmm sounds like you're hating to me
people are like in my hair thing
i um good luck ethan took a gamble
and i'm glad you like what hair thing
it's just it's like a little
stain the [ __ ] is this it's like
[Laughter]
you're such a fashion icon bro
so anyway i learned so i'm sorry to do
politics i know we don't do politics
here but these this is just gaffes right
we just like i learned
listen to any rules here like
no we haven't been on time following our
own
rules we have rule that's not one of the
rules incidentally
we have always been late did you guys
know it just recently came out and again
donald trump had a coke
a diet coke button i love it on his
presidential desk
in fact they called it they have a name
for that desk it's called the
the resolute desk jesus i'm throwing it
down it's not that serious it's just a
desk
so i immediately wanted to hate on it
but i gotta say if ethan if you were
president you would totally have
that coke button like i'm not sure i
would have a die i'd just be like excuse
me
don't you call him or yeah but then
you're like i got a call
so you're telling me this button sole
purpose is just bring me a diet coke
like it's gotta just be summoned the
butler or something
but according to they call them dumps
yeah
according to according to the press it
was the sole purpose of this button
you know it was reported that he drank
like 15 diet cokes a day which
i don't know how you live like i mean
sometimes i'll drink like two in a day
and i feel like my body's decaying from
the inside out yeah
i i'll drink like half and i start to
feel bad
yeah no it's it's not good diet coke is
like like bro you know if you're
drinking chemicals it tastes sweet but
have no calories you're like oh yeah
that's
that's but that's horrible um
so by the way he immediately got removed
he removed the diet coke button well i
don't
you know if you don't like diet coke
what's the point of the button
can you reprogram it to the coffee
that's what i would
no you need to do that's a different
button
um ian did say that it sounds like a lot
of presidents had it before
you know yeah oh ian brings out the
receipts of course
yeah this is another trump classic tweet
i have never seen a thin person drinking
diet coke
which is hilarious by the way and true
especially in his case
i do like it right it's such a funny
thing to tweet as pres as the president
it would be great i know but
what i think it's funny from someone
who's not a president
but isn't it funnier like if obama had
tweets in 2012 saying i have think that
thin people i've never seen a thin
person drinking a diet coke
no
anyway um okay and before i get into all
the drama that we're
really all here to talk about i have to
touch on something really bizarre i
learned this morning
yeah and forgive me zach
i have to this is just so odd please i
beg you i beg
of you i'm sorry is that coming okay so
bizarre
okay can you tell me why you feel this
way okay
it's bad luck i'm not saying i don't
like the music
i'm not saying that it's every time it
comes on
something bad happens huh and you think
i'm i'm [ __ ] okay well wait what crazy
i'll disprove that
what you said even knows what we're
talking about a little bit
well i'm not saying it well we haven't
explained yet because
tell me tell me bad things that happen
when that when this when their music was
on
um car accidents something bad happens
to someone
speeding tickets just a weird [ __ ]
day
just like all right so there's a
specific
band a very famous band that zach feels
is absolutely cursed and he freaks out
when i say it or play it or he hears it
anywhere for example a b
you were driving tell me tell me what
you were telling before we went live
yeah we were going to the mark rivier
concert a while ago and i put on uh
credence clearwater oh you [ __ ]
he said it
i wasn't gonna say it zach we were
jamming out he like turned off my radio
and he's like don't do that and i was
like i thought i like did something
against his religion or something but
yeah he freaked out
so what is the band i because i'm not
familiar with it it's just like a
classic rock band
okay a really beloved one yeah whatever
truly
zach would have been a big fan of zach
if we if we can't even say like the
initials of the name
yeah i i can't even i can't imagine no
no like just the letters
well zach can i just can i just i kind
of want to get in your head a little bit
because you say every time it plays
something bad happens
i mean the fact that you listen to it
with a b and nothing bad happened
kind of disproves that doesn't it well
you have a five-second grace period
oh really yeah what you're making
immediately i'm all turn that [ __ ] off
right now like i'm i was dead seriously
well maybe did you
play did that seriously be like it was
weird yeah no he made me turn it off
so amy did you turn it off before five
seconds
i don't think so no i think he thinks it
was playing longer than five seconds yet
nothing bad happened do you see what i'm
saying
we were playing it earlier nothing bad
has happened well
it's not over dan and we're roasting you
live on the show i just i don't want you
to live with this
trauma zach i think we need to get you
through this i i you know i've actually
legitimately talked to my shrink about
it really
and like what did he say about it she's
like
she's she's like she's like yeah like
everyone has superstitions and
i just i just can't [ __ ] with it i just
can't it just seems like it's enhanced
it's it's causing an impedament on your
life like imagine you're on a date and
then she puts on oh that's how
you're like stop don't do that she's
like what is she gonna
she's gonna leave you she's gonna think
you're such a weirdo i was in a
restaurant that happened
i'm like i i have to excuse myself like
i'm not even joking
zach you cannot carry this around i
i i'm [ __ ] my life up it it [ __ ] my
life what if you just say the name like
20 times
just face it you know straight on we
have to test this
like if we if you if i
say okay so what's the rules cause i say
the name or it has to play the music
what are the rules
tell me everything is a problem you just
even the the mention of looking at the
main guy like i was on twitter and
something popped up and i'm like [ __ ]
like but nothing bad happened that day
that's what i mean
well the day isn't over yet yeah but
back then you said a picture pop up to
the guy and you closed it no that's the
day
that was today oh so your whole day's
been cursed with this guy
and then coincidentally there was an
ethan bradberry video where this all
started
and he was playing a song from that
specific group yeah he sent it to us
and then i was watching and he's like
wait i just realized what's playing in
the background turn it off
what do you mean ethan bradberry started
this it was
today he posted a video and the
background of
bradbury's video was cc well i i
understand that but what do you mean
ethan bradberry started all this because
zach sent
i want to hear from zach he started the
conversation
because i'm like oh no no no turn that
off turn that off i i realized
as i after i sent it to
our chat that um there was a certain
song playing
okay so your your phobia existed before
the ethan bradbury incident
but you sent it to this chat and then
you erased it from the chat
no it's still in the chat oh boy oh
boy and but nothing's bad happened since
you sent it in the chat you understand
what i'm saying oh no this is happening
this is a nightmare
yeah but see this doesn't count this
doesn't count as something bad we're
just victor here
said i listened to i'm not gonna say it
for you
thank you eloh thank you every time
before an exam so far i haven't flunked
once not cursed knockers yeah i mean
millions of people every day listen to
this band i
i understand i've blocked them from my
spotify from
my what
zach feels a bad moon rising oh you
[ __ ]
oh i already bought a lot of those puns
earlier
zach this day's already ruined so i feel
like what does it matter if we saturate
it with more
what if what if you're fishing and
somebody goes boy that water looks clear
i mean that's how about that clear water
what about that
that's fine i guess just like the term
credence would [ __ ] me up
credence it's the credence that gets you
it's just bad
[ __ ] man it just you know you think i'm
crazy
it's just bad [ __ ] jesus do your parents
know about this
yeah they do how do you hide it from
anybody
well no it's they're like okay you know
you have
bad luck [ __ ] you know like i just i
just can't [ __ ] with it i love like
somebody put a spell on you dude
well you know super chat
yo pull that up either yeah yo sorry i
gotta put a pin in that zac
there's a music video with 323 million
views where some where the main guy is
wearing our color block cody
this is actually from the super chat let
me read the comments that's crazy
they said did you guys know that i
i don't know how to read this radiation
reggaeton
in the music video of a platinum
award-winning song
i did not somehow i did not know that i
feel like i already
did not know that how did we miss this
thing yo
well this is from even a year ago it's
like not new
it's it's actually two years ago sorry
year and a half
but i actually want to share with you
all that we're working on
um a 2.0 version of this hoodie
so next time it's it's going to come
back
and a few restock colors but yeah
updating some
like the pocket structure and the logo
is it going to say sisters on the front
no it's going to say
[Laughter]
um it actually looks so good i am so the
2.0 is not until now it's still
this is from our first ever release i
know it's so crazy so
crazy so it still has the like the very
first logo that was my hand drawing but
since then we've
changed it on everything except we keep
restocking this
we always got the old logo so we felt it
was time to
like let's do it it looks 2.0
the fit is a little nicer everything is
just
dialed up you know sister we got so much
better at making clothes
okay anyway back to zach because zach
what are we going to do about please
i have a little bit of a suspicion zack
zack's favorite movie in the world
is um the big lebowski
i have to skip those scenes what and in
the big lebowski
if i recall it correct me if i'm wrong
doesn't he get into a car accident while
listening to credence in that movie
uh yes sir yes he does you just want to
be jeff bridges this is just
no no no no no this started this started
they started even before
wait wait wait as a little kid oh you
just want to be the dude
yeah i mean i've seen the big lebowski
like a billion times i never thought
about that
but zack how is it that the big lebowski
can be your favorite movie if that song
is so cursed to you
it's not my favorite movie it's one of
my favorite movies how's that possible
shouldn't you just not watch that movie
all together if it's so cursed well
no you skipped the scenes dude and then
skipped the scene
your favorite movie and at the same time
skip scenes
this is this is the hell i live in my
joker brain
stop with the joker brain oh my this
isn't joker brain this is just
stop this is odd bro i'm telling you you
guys think i'm crazy
you know but this is just straight facts
and i
believe what else happened to you as a
result like speeding ticket
not a big deal there's just been also
your fault not ccr's
hmm true were you speeding zach
just like just were you speeding yes
okay
yeah i have a feeling you were speeding
before the song came on
that's not the only circumstance just
just weird [ __ ]
happens okay tell me everything that's
happened you said you were in a car
crash
i want to know everything that's
happened and then let me draw a
conclusion if the song is cursed or not
there was like one instance when i was
in my college days
and i was with my buddy and we heard it
in the car
and he ended up like slipping and
falling like immediately after
and then the rest of the day he got
written up because we were like
was he gravely injured or something no
no no but it's just
weird minor [ __ ] just [ __ ] happened
what grade was this son
uh he was in uh he was a sophomore in
college
okay he how do you get written up in
college what is that well
we we were we were at a party at his
college and we were on the balcony
having beers
and the [ __ ] r.a like picked up on it
and it was just
it just just all things that could go
wrong so let me get this straight
a song was playing he tripped and fell
he was not injured at all
well you know just a few scrapes and
[ __ ] you know yeah
later in the day you got written up how
do you attribute the write-up to the
song
because i feel like it wouldn't have
happened
how do you make that connection that's
just like you're talking you're talking
about like 12
hours later whoa ela oh what the f
either move the desk up button it's one
of those standing there i got scared
because all the wires and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's right it's it's haunted
now because it is sure
yeah see what i [ __ ] mean
nothing happened the desk just went
i love how zack's vietnam flashbacks are
like i got a speeding ticket in my
friend
my friends my friend tripped and he was
totally fine
there's been you see the table went up
and nothing happened
yeah you see there's a channel
there's a chance there's a chance that
wouldn't have happened if we weren't
talking about it
but nothing bad happened it's a shitty
curse it's
not a boat in curse it's a very
something literally all that happens
okay what else happened
so your friend people want us to move on
my show my rules what else happened can
i read a few um
people are saying um
wait where did they go is that it zach
is there anything else
it's just bad okay okay
what how much to get you in a room and
just blast
that music soldiers all stream ccr at
the same time to release zach from the
spell
oh you have to like that's cruel
why not even gonna hear it just like
everybody
do you approve if everyone unhexes you
in the chat no
why are you not even going to hear it he
thinks he's getting a super curse
see now i hear one of the songs in my
head and i can't sing it
sing it no just sing it you'll release
do you have that much faith in your
singing really i thought it was funny
everybody wants to tell me how to run my
show and the thing is people compare me
to the dude's voice all the time which
[ __ ] my head up hmm how humble
i don't want to be compared to satan i
mean
shut the [ __ ] up how dare you devil he's
the devil he's the devil he's the devil
god
like you're so weird about you're losing
it you gotta get it together
there's a few requests for my um outfit
4-1-1
what is that for i guess like the
details like what am i wearing
um vintage
vintage all right so guys we have a lot
to catch up on
not much yeah just keep keep them coming
keep them coming all right so like we we
have we did frenemies last week
and you know i feel bad for trisha she's
going through a lot
yeah actually she totally it all
escalated
it escalated big time over like man
trisha's life moves fast because like
i'm
just at home doing my thing and then all
of a sudden at one am i see
like this video on the subreddit let me
show you how fast
[ __ ] escalating and trisha's life
her latest video oh she put it on her
second video i don't understand the
logic of that
i felt like i was following everything
and then yesterday i was just not really
on the internet that much
kind of working all day and all of a
sudden there's like so much that
happened
okay so here's the title of her newest
video shane and rylan
are literal scum of the earth jesus
like how how do you wrestle here in just
one day
i think what happened is maybe i should
tell a story but ryland
was doing a podcast
and maybe i'll just show it i think we
have a time stamp let me do a saw an
order
here
did you time stamp this here come on man
here death noodles got us time's tempt
it
so rylan responded to basically
everything trish has been saying and the
jeffree star stuff and
people were not happy at all in fact he
was getting dragged so hard before trish
even got involved
he disabled the comments and likes on
his video which you know means
oh brother you lost that battle boy
[Music]
jesus
so let's see what he said in response to
trisha
and i hate to do this because trish's
friendship means
more to me than a headlining story on
this podcast i hate that
we're a podcast that does hot topics and
i've somehow
lived by the sword die boy the sword
[ __ ]
sometimes you spill that piping hot tea
in your own lap and trust me i've
learned that better than anybody we've
learned that
you you know what i mean it's it's a
[ __ ] doggy dog world out there dude
you want to talk [ __ ] you want sip tea
well get ready [ __ ] because i'm about
to put your ass in the kettle yeah
jesus calm down come on man this is my
enemy now
the enemy of my friend of me is my enemy
the enemy of my friend me is my arch
enemy come on come on man come on man
you can talk you're gonna find your
friend come on
topic that i feel i love that trump's
out and now it's just all abide in me
that's the way it should be man i love
it come on the peaceful transition of
power
yeah the semi-peaceful transition of
power i'll call it
i have to address me in some sort of way
because i've seen
i've been flooded on all all elements of
social media regarding
this situation and you think he likes
pepsi whatever
is um i'm just saying like pep
like bro what's pepsi got you on payroll
or what
come on man you know what i'm saying
what the [ __ ] it's not such a big deal
i mean bro you got any coke gear or what
are you only pepsi
that's not a big deal come on man
us right now and i guess the only come
on
i'm i'm confused i was taken back a
little bit
and i understand like she's had drama
with jeffrey and hair by jay who has
hair by jay obviously said horrific
things that i don't stand by
i don't support obviously i support
trisha over here by jay like
by the way i notice there's a really
good distinction he makes here
he's she he says she has drama with
her by jay and jeffrey starr i support
her over here by jay
yeah i didn't mention jeffree star i'm
immediately thinking like when he's
saying that like well
the situation was held by jay and
jeffrey it's not
exactly that's what trisha was saying
it's like it's really separate
there's a reason here by jay saying all
this [ __ ] and here by jay by himself
doesn't give a [ __ ] it's all he's all
doing it to please
lord jeffrey lord joffrey can i just
start calling oh
come on man we gotta start calling damn
jeffrey josh as much as i'm loath to
bring back any game of thrones memes
that's that's too good that's it you
guys heard it here the new meme
new meme generated joffrey stars
for like new meme generated oh that's
good
generated like a fight like a street
fighter
i guess i didn't think about that but
that works
yo he is so much like joffrey he's like
this bitch-ass
cannon just playing with people
for his entertainment i threw her bluncy
out in the garbage sorry [ __ ] i don't
know where your balenciaga is
okay joffrey hey get over here
whoa nice came up with that quick what
then uh just quick aside uh
because somebody donated a hundred
dollars and uh and it says this 100
donation of protection read this
donation to protect all podcast crew
members
from all music related curses for the
next 20 years
lifted the curse dude thank you but
let's see how the rest of the day goes
okay no what if zach just no thank you
bot
really what because he was like thank
you
but but oh yeah no thank you but
all right let's watch let's not get too
distracted we're just getting steamed up
joffrey anyway thank you for the
donation people say i'm not grateful
enough i'm just it's not that i'm not
grateful it's just
this isn't the thing is this isn't that
type of stream i'm trying to do a show
you know i am not
too distracted i constantly feel bad
about it and i really
want to establish that it
we just can't be like that it's not what
we want for the show so it's not that
we're not grateful
with peace and love there's a good
chance your donations will not be
observed
and the audience is the one who keeps
telling us about it honestly
we were checking if we can put a cap on
how much you can donate so that
we wouldn't like you know which
apparently you feel bad but it doesn't
do yeah it doesn't let you do that okay
let's continue anyway
love you guys thank you so much god
bless
ryland
followed this man i don't know this man
i've met him
once in about joffrey yeah and
the fact he's afraid of jeff jo of josh
i'm so heavily involved with this
really does break my heart because i
love trisha so much yeah i
consider her one of my closest friends
we see her more than
i see really anyone besides you because
you come over weekly for this podcast
and i guess at the end of the day i
truly
wish she would have come to me as a
friend if she was hurting like
the way that she is and talked it out
with me
and i wish that it wouldn't have played
out on the internet like this i just
am really honestly confused
because so she of course trish was like
i have told you so many times
yeah i have told you guys about this so
many times i mean he's really missing
the point because he's like [ __ ]
here by j joffrey on the other hand we
love joffrey it seems like he's
conveniently missing the point
of course he is um
i mean i feel like i'm kind of new to
this whole situation but like it's
immediately
obvious to me that what trisha is saying
is true
and jeffrey is a major major douchebag
like it doesn't seem like it's that hard
to come to that conclusion
you can't even deny it and if you guys
were close friends
it's like you knew all that so the and
then the part that
bothers trish is that every time she
told them about it
they would say like oh he's dangerous
how do we get away from that and then
all of a sudden it's like they
it's like she feels like she they're
just blowing smoke up her ass yeah i see
her all of the time
and even after the last time jefferson
also can shane say something like who
the [ __ ] like
with peace and love ryland i mean i
don't really give a [ __ ] about what you
think but
i'm assuming you're just speaking from
on behalf of shane
physically on this podcast i was at her
house and we had a wonderful
loving time and i understand maybe it's
hard for her to
express her actual feelings towards
jeffrey
to us or the gravity in which she's
feeling feelings towards jeffrey when
she knows we're specifically
friendly with jeffrey so maybe it's hard
so he says they're from the world
team joffrey you're not kings with
you're not
friends with so then okay so that
happened and then all these other people
started coming out with
[ __ ] reseats baby when did this turn
into a drama
channel but i love it where like
receipts
they came out with the recipes i mean
the receipts
so oscar wilde by the way so now this
gets this gets all
[ __ ] weird and wild oscar wilde was
apparently he's a dj and he was
on that trip yeah i know
kind of a famous author oh yeah
one of my favorite books picture dorian
gray oh i tried reading that i thought
it was so [ __ ] boring i was like oh
my god
dude with peace and love of course
anyway he okay so here we go he was
there
on that faithful fateful trip
he says yeah i've been too kind and kept
my mouth shut for too long but the only
thing i will say publicly right now is
that yes
i physically was asked by joffrey at
what point do i cut ties
with shane like this is more than street
three strikes literally this [ __ ] day
after tati filmed her video
i'm not trying to bring people into this
but i truly feel my kindness or empathy
was taken advantage of and i just feel
bad for the fact that trisha lost a
friend
for signing with someone i physically
watched say that they said that
so apparently joffrey's not only talking
[ __ ] about trisha he's also talking [ __ ]
about
shane you know and then it comes out
that shane has been talking [ __ ] about
trisha
uh come on man come on man
you know what it's hard to explain i'm
just gonna get into it with her on
monday but
here's really the best thing that came
out of this
james charles enters the [ __ ] scene
bro
it's so liberating when people finally
start to see what you've been seeing all
along
and then i i messaged trisha when i saw
this i was like
20 21 is the weirdest year ever this is
becoming a pro
james charles podcast and an anti-shame
podcast
the whole world has flipped upside down
in the mat in the course of one
week one week snatched yeah
it's when joe biden became president
everything changed that day
everything changed that day i'm trying
to find
you don't we have the clip here guys of
when what shane was saying
talking [ __ ] about
uh trisha
come on man come on man either of you
guys know
maybe it's in the front of his dock let
me check maybe he's on it
yeah go ahead i
was just going to say we're um uh at the
break time
oh okay so you look that up i'm going to
thank hbo
max who's really daddy as [ __ ]
um can you send me the coffee i did
uh okay it says no subject it's the
second thing in the inbox this is for me
oh i linked that thing at discord hbo
max hbo max is a streaming platform
that bundles all of hbo together with
even more
of your favorite movies iconic shows
like friend friends
iconic wow
and fresh prince of bel air
plus new max originals streaming from
all of your favorite devices
and download top titles to watch on the
go
bingeable collections handpicked by
humans not robots
i think hbo max is going to be huge it's
going to be like definitely a big
rival i love that i love that they did
it because they had before like
different
apps and it was all confusing so now
it's just one
i know yeah yeah exactly i was
like hbo max is hbo now this hbo goes
like i don't know but now hbo
max
uh sorry damn so there's other things is
now hbo max is teamed up with
dc and they're bringing the expansive
selection of
superhero content straight up to hbo max
hbo max is the u.s home for all of my
favorite dc content and they are saving
the day because i could download my
favorite
of saving the day like a hero would
because i can download my favorite
titles and watch them
anywhere on the go i'm talking about
wonder woman
justice league star girl batwoman
hbo's shazam suicide squad
the list goes on and on
and on and on
and not only can you download movies and
shows to watch on your devices on the go
hbo max also offers exclusive content
you can't find anywhere else
you know what's exciting is um not only
do they have all of the dc movies and
everything but they do have
batman the animated series yes i was so
i was just gonna
recommend some stuff on um hbo maximum
maximus max so the animated series one
of the most beloved cartoons of all time
it's like the most like
one of my good yeah so freaking good oh
my and you know mark hamill is the joker
in that [ __ ] which is i never knew that
i didn't know but i always know it as a
kid
it's great because like it's that joker
voice is so iconic
it's like more joker than anything he's
he's the joker
he's like mark hamill because everybody
i just assumed his cr
he was just luke and that was it but he
had a very prolific
voice acting career yep
you know as besides let's see here
um man they have a lot of stuff
they've got everything tons of batman
content all the superhero [ __ ]
there's also so much other good stuff on
hbo max for example i cannot recommend
um god what was the show oh lovecraft
country
oh my god do you ever watch that dance
show the foot unfortunately i haven't
i'm like like i have to beg you to watch
it i don't really want to watch it i
just
haven't gotten around to it yet that's
one of my favorite shows of the whole
year
yeah just the best lovecraft country
amazing obviously they have
curb which is like god mode
god mode anyway
right now new and returning subscribers
can sign up for a limited time
time pre-pay and save offer
uh to say you can save 20 when you
prepay the first six months of an hbo
max subscription
offer ends march 5th first so get on it
fast boy
they've got something for everyone every
day check out the link in the
description
and get 20 off the first prepaid six
months of your hbo max
subscription love it i'm so happy to be
sponsored
i love hbo anyway back to the show
it's like a snap out of a coma after the
copyright like okay guys copyright
hbo max all right we're back
i gotta do that from now on all right
you want to do q on meltdowns
did you find the link maybe uh yeah yeah
they sent it
where in the discord yeah oh thank you
oh we already got my photoshop how is
that
is this cam grants without even
i want to hire cam grants he's such a
god look
hey i gotta zoom out so i can see the
whole thing
[Music]
it looks too much like joffrey i think
it needs to be jeffrey's face
because that's joffrey
anyway i love it yeah the t
cam grant's always on it um
let me check i wanna say you look great
ethan no they're not
they are nobody said that well here's
one ethan does look great
he's gone he left
that's
you guys serious ethan looks like he
lost weight looking great
and eli you're a queen whatever you do
look like you've gone but did you guys
see how hot he looked do you really say
that whoa
are you saying that i am reading your
comments that people even paid 70s are
i don't know what czar but wherever
no i'm not rude i'm appreciative and
south african right your compliments are
going worldwide
that's about a piece of love there has
they're getting compliments in different
currencies
wow that's nearly eastern us an
international icon and i know you've
seen this too
when i'm fat and gaining weight i'm at
my max
i still see comments and it's bizarre
they say ethan's lose
weight and it's got tons of likes and i
go what no not always
so beautiful no that's a compliment that
means something
no huh
well because i'm at a point here where
i've been working really hard pretty
much exercising every day
for over a month and i'm at the point
where it's like am i losing weight i
kind of think maybe i am but it's hard
to tell you know what i mean
your compliments mean everything to me
that's hot
okay oh this was the guy thank you and
this is exactly what i was looking for
so this guy who i don't know who peter
mon is but
so apparent according to this guy and
this is the most hurtful [ __ ] i think
this is what pushed trisha over the edge
to make
the video about them he made a video
saying that shane has been talking [ __ ]
about trisha
behind her back i mean these guys are
all just thickest thieves man there's
like no
loyalty between these beauty gurus and i
can tell you
trisha is one of the most fiercely loyal
people
there is on the planet like she has been
so loving and protective of shane and
the fact that he would even say a single
bad thing i meet shane dawson and shane
dawson talks about all these people
behind you know their backs
like he even said things about trisha
paytas i've talked about this on here
you know that like
trisha had said something to me to the
effect of like if i had known you you
were going to be in vegas
and shane was going to be in vegas and i
would have flown out there and i said
something to him and he goes well she's
a hypo
or she's a pathological liar and they
all kind of laughed
and i'm like okay so this is how you
talk about somebody that defends you at
any expense this is how you talk about
because i just
i didn't know like it's weird you know
when you're saying she's not
a liar i know she said she used to be
trisha i have not known her to lie about
anything
she she'll embellish you know what i
mean but she doesn't lie
she'll embellish at times when she's
like angry or upset or something but
i have not known her to lie about
anything
so [ __ ] shane there i said it
[Music]
team james charles all the way wow
sister snapped
but at the end of the day i really do
think that that
joffrey star is probably the worst of
them all
me too he still has fans i mean how is
it possible although unlikely
i think uh i mean like
my thoughts on shane are starting to be
kind of like what's going on there
well well yeah watching those videos
about him
oh my god you know what putting like
this whole story is kind of bizarre to
me
considering how much of a good friend
trisha was to him
oh so i i can put this out there because
trish just said it
but so trisha shane asked trisha
to remove certain videos from her
channel
when all this drama was coming down
about him being like creepy with
underage people
and she hasn't specifically said what
those videos were
so i'm not gonna put it i'm not gonna
put anything out there
but like i know that some of the [ __ ]
that he
immediately told her to remove is some
mega [ __ ] up [ __ ]
i don't know
and she did it here let me let me get a
little someone saying she lied about
your family though
she like what did she say about my
family no
i think her whole drama with her and
like the family comments and
what was happening i feel like we've all
kind of like
learned right now over the few last few
months to
we kind of learned how to understand
each other i think i get it
i think she was thinking like sometimes
ethan in her mind was pushing her for
reactions even though
in in your mind you're not really
pushing her for reactions like if she's
upset you're not trying to trigger her
more
but she thought so and she was thinking
that
when she was giving comments like that
about our family she was kind of like
doing that to you
i think she wasn't lying what she was
doing is like
taking something small and turning it
into something big
you know but i feel like we've kind of
we're kind of understanding each other
better now let me put it this way she
would never just
go like ethan did this thing that he
never did yeah
she wouldn't just make up a straight up
lie
like i wouldn't call her a pathological
liar at all she's an ex she's an
exaggerator at times exaggerated
but usually when she's angry yeah anyway
i want to see a little bit of what she
says here hey guys
so um i i'm like really
really trying to stay off you like her
uh
i could never care less about all this
like israeli stuff
i can't listen to what she's saying
without commenting the fact that she has
a life-size
beetlejuice sculpture behind her in her
[ __ ] bedroom you guys
who and then also she got the
beetlejuice snake worm thing
above her bed like holy [ __ ] trisha
that's so next level
bruh bruh
and state of panic state of
disbelief and just really trying to
bite my tongue on so many things 30
minutes
but it's insane the more things that
come out
so let me give you a little more
background on my
friendship with shane dawson like this
is this is crazy this is insane
this is insane and i'll tell there's
there's just like how do you know okay
yeah a piece of love i mean 32 minutes
you know couples but
oh my god come on man
i feel bad for her because these are
people she loves
you know pathological liar like thank
you
i hope you get kissed by garth brooks
the kiss of death
anyway let's move on i have nothing else
to say about it i like that
[Music]
you guys want to watch some q a on
meltdowns i know it sounds political but
i promise it's really fun i
promise just give it a chance you guys
are going to love it unless you're a q a
believer in which case
i don't know why you're here you know
what i mean
i love it this is not a q friendly
uh string okay so here well this is the
kind of [ __ ] that just blows my [ __ ]
mind
and by the way every cube believer
literally looks like they're from the
same family
come on now come on anna i read on that
facebook now that q
gonna be taken over there special come
on suey
come on now piggy
they're all white trash is what i'm
trying to say i actually have heard that
um
or heard i saw an article i didn't
actually read it but
it was on new york times about this lady
who's like
an old successful lady in manhattan
and she's all queuing on yeah to tell
you the truth that's that stereo
that stereotype isn't really true for
this q a phenomenon it's
mostly middle-class people that call for
well we'll see
but but you know i think i think people
who are just really prone to
conspiratorial thinking
because there's a lot of people that buy
into conspiracy theories and then
facebook which is just
such a [ __ ] up platform
just funnels all these people who are
already conspiratorial
have kind of like paranoid uh there's
something called like paranoid
there's some kind of paranoia disorder
where like you're just super paranoid
about how you think and it makes you
prone to believing really crazy
conspiracy theories
and so facebook takes all these [ __ ]
people that are already in like
9 11 was the inside job or whatever and
then funnels them all
into q anon and then the very fact that
there's so many people there makes them
think that it's real
yeah and it's like this whole anyway
just like
just listen to this well this is that
moment when all the uh
trump supporters that had faith or at
least said they had faith
don't lose your faith now boys right now
but uh we're succeeding boys still have
actual faith
are relaxed calm chilling
because they know that there's nothing
that can stop what's coming
let me tell you people biden is never
going
to be the president
[Music]
of our country just because he just
swore in does not
make him officially there are documents
that have to be signed
all this means right now is that there
is no acting president
because the transfer of power is in the
midst and taking place right now because
right now constitutional lawyer just sit
back and watch
and be patient interesting they're so
dead like they're the gymnastics the
mental gymnastics people are doing
they're so lost at this point yeah
if you just scroll down
i mean look these people sorry but with
peace and love this is a suey
come on now
for everyone who watched president
trump's farewell speech
i hope you listened very carefully to
what he was saying
but i hope you act they're all like fbi
detectives now
i
i hope you took all the first letters of
all the second words
it adds for acronym for this storm is
coming now i know it's off by three
letters and three words but trust me now
boss
just be patient free victory
i hope you were paying attention to the
background
if you look at the flags that were
behind him
you will have noticed the gold fringe
[Music]
come on man the goat okay why do some
american flags have gold fringes the
gold french flag is a clear sign of
system being in place it is not the
system we are taught to believe is in
place what
a goldfinch flag was sourcefully used
during times of war and maritime
admirality law oh [ __ ] i hope you all
were paying attention
to that what is an american vlog with a
gold fringe
i just i wish that the cam camera angle
was just a little bit closer to her face
oh the gold fringes i see that i mean i
see that sometimes
i feel like i've seen it all over the
place yeah
hope you guys we're paying close
attention
the gold fringes means
that trump is about to throw biden in
prison for sex trafficking of children
you better get your popcorn ready get
your popcorn ready now how do they
think that trump is the man one hell of
a movie that you're about to see
yeah no even someone who is at the party
because you're going to need it because
they say he was undercover
they they truly believe that he's a
warrior against pedophilia and the guy
he has his own allegations what can you
say what can you say
what can you say you there's more i mean
there's always more
so they're all posted i'm assuming
they're all posting this to like
is this the storm is coming facebook
page but no it's this there's an app
called clapper which is like uh clap
those cheeks
i clap those cheeks it's uh it's
it's like a free speech tick tock
clone kind of thing from what i
understand
brother is it just people like this it's
just
who wants to be the clapper agent
let's see go ahead and download clapper
yeah please
sign up for clapper and i want you to
put that on my computer
i want you to you know i want you to
post and see if you can become a big
account there
see if you can get a thousand followers
clap those cheeks it seems like a damn
mission to me
i can't i'm switching that's business no
i don't i don't mean like right now i
just mean in general i want to move
on i could do it later yeah um people
want to
hear your thoughts satan on the claudia
conway
story people want to hear my thoughts on
that um
so to give background i mean claudia
conway she's really popular on tick tock
she's the daughter of
kellyanne conway george and kellyanne
conway yeah kellyanne conway who was
the senior advisor to president trump a
very prominent
senior advisor to him and she's been
posting
pictures she's been [ __ ] with her
parents so much
like secretly recording them putting it
on tick tock recently she put up a tick
tock over mom just being
super i mean yeah abusive it definitely
seems like to me i mean i feel bad for
her
so obviously first of all she's like 15
16 years old so
obviously you can't put any blame on her
if that house is [ __ ] up and broken
it's obviously
her parents fault so i see a lot of
people saying mean stuff about her i do
too and i'm like
excuse me she's a [ __ ] six-year-old
girl like shut the [ __ ] up
i mean i don't remember having
encounters like that with my mom
well her mom was saying like horrible
things for her and throwing [ __ ] at her
and just
oh it's just just i mean
sorry but like if your child is doing
that it's definitely your fault as
parents
i mean that house is so [ __ ] up
because her mom
is senior advisor to president trump
like straight down the rabbit hole of
trumpism
magga and then her dad is one of the
founding
prominent members of the lincoln project
who is like the sworn
nemesis of trumpism how does that go
together that house
must be like insane yeah
you think you think yourself wow i
wonder how they make that work and then
you see her daughter and you're like oh
they're not making it work it's horrible
it's a nightmare and the daughter was
like she got covered from her mom right
oh she got covered from the president
and then gave it to her
yeah so the president literally gave
this girl covet
i would be upset too
and she's trying to i i don't know if i
if there's any more specific thoughts
you want
i didn't want to show the tick tock
because it's just it's actually just
like
it's kind of hard child abuse yeah
you know she's saying super wicked [ __ ]
to her daughter like
[ __ ] that a mom shouldn't ever say to a
daughter you know what i mean
yeah that's awful
i it was hard to watch for me i don't
think anybody should be saying anything
about that poor girl i mean even if
whatever you think about her she's 16
years old i mean she's a product of her
environment like
all right have some like [ __ ] you don't
say anything about her
dare you i mean and at her age to have
to deal with like everything you put out
goes immediately into a news story
i think it's it's it's kind of like
obviously she's putting her parents in a
really tough situation that's pretty
epic to be
secretly filming your mom who's one of
the most prominent people in politics
and then blowing her up on tick tock
every week
but like you know get your [ __ ]
family in order lady
come on man come on man okay
did i answer the questions or any more
specific things anyway here let's listen
to the
let's let's listen to candace jennifer
clap on them cheeks
okay so um i want to put this out here
for especially the liberals
who keep calling trump supporters uh
like they're in a cult
you guys are the cults you're following
trumpets the 45
cults you do realize
that free thinkers cannot be in a cult
they're not in a cult
if you're in a cult you're just
listening to everything that's told to
you and believe everything that is
said to you instead of doing a reason so
think about that okay you're in the cult
she got oh
you're in the cult because you just
believe everything that's about you on
the news
you're so smart wow
blew my [ __ ] mind she did
and it's so weird they all think all of
a sudden they're smarter than everyone
they think because they get their
information from alternative places that
they're
yeah well informed or that they have the
real story
we do the real reason you you read the
new york times
cute i get my info from the storm is
coming
where one goes one goes i'll go q
facebook
post don't win um trump.win
megan wrote can we not watch politics
how is this politics
sorry this is all called i love talking
about cults this is a cult
yeah come on this isn't politics this
next one uh
it's probably my favorite talking about
this cue character how does that
politics
with peace and love well let me just say
i i understand that you don't want to
talk about politics but with peace and
love this is great
so guys uh turns out
i think you've got to shine a light on
this we cannot accept this as normal no
these people are abnormal by the way
they don't
represent a normal republican voter i
respect all americans and people that
vote for trump or conservatives or
anything
i hold no ill will against them but this
is abnormal we need to shine a light on
we can't just
put this [ __ ] in the corner and be like
oh well you know
no it's actually really sad these people
have fallen for a head
it's destructive brain washed whatever
belief and they're actually ruining
their own lives
i mean this is the fall of society if
there's a huge segment of the population
that start to believe things that are
literally based on nothing
like the whole storm of the capital
thing was based these people believe
with all their hearts and souls
something that literally
never happened we have to shine a light
on we cannot just ignore this [ __ ]
because
you know when enough people start
believing [ __ ] like that then then
society doesn't i don't even see how is
this politics like we're not even
talking any
actual politics no this
you know guys
turns out i was wrong
donald trump is not going to be
inaugurated
tomorrow
but neither is joe biden oh here come
play the um
play the um vsauce music get that get
the vsauce music
[Music]
i can't watch this without vsauce music
it comes in right as it gets close to
the camera
hi v shot can you imagine vsauce here
today
i'm going to be explaining how joe biden
is a the kingpin of an underground
pedophile ring
so guys ah turns out okay wait
zach play it when he gets all close to
the camera i got it oh okay
i was wrong donald trump
is not going to be inaugurated tomorrow
january 20th but neither is joe biden
so i guess it all starts in 1871.
because that's how we're going here let
me give you a little history lesson
in my chick-fil-a uniform in my car this
has actually been a country
apparently can you turn it up we've been
a corporation him
owned by the city of london sorry
clapton this is how far back this goes
we're owned by london been a country
guys
clap those cheeks um all intel says that
pelosi biden harris all intel hence
guys i heard on the facebook page
that all the intel goes to show that
biden
harris pants are all
board members on the london city owns
and uh when the inauguration hold on one
second
you all wanted the uh y'all wanted the
spicy chicken sandwich or the
anyways around there'll be nobody
ratified by the senate to take the seat
right therefore
the contract with the city of london is
null and void
i come from the country i think it's a
country of london uh let me correct you
there
is why the military is my friend at work
was crying the other day because you
full-heartedly believe in queuing on and
was
crying thinking that she's going to get
rounded up
guys this is not okay that there's a
huge swath of people that believe that
people are going to be literally round
up and put in re-education camps they
think that
the democrats are going to round up all
conservatives and put them in
re-education camps you guys
clap those this is not okay this is not
okay
wait like hello what the [ __ ] is going
on
as dense as they are in dc
because they will take custody is this
redneck uh
michael all along this coast from there
vsauce what's his last name
michael i'm gonna say scott but that's
not it
wait what what's his last name yes do we
not know
uh oh he just says michael v stevens
michael michael stevens of course
this is redneck michael stevens
and all along this coast from there to
there
because the navy is lined up you can see
them as far as the horizon goes those
cheeks north all the way to south
zach you might be riding that one a
little harder
that's why all in this region right here
there's so many aircraft it's like you
can't even see through when you're on
the radar
i just prefer not making fun of whole
groups of poor people to make fun of cue
cult
okay fair enough i accept that as
criticism and it's the chill on that
i accept and i still assert from
everything i've researched about these
people it's
not it's not really poor people it's
middle class suburban
whites i accept that criticism and in
the words of trump i love the poor
i love the poorly educated and the poor
people
they're my base you guys make up my
whole audience
[Laughter]
yeah no i i listen yeah how do i make
fun of q
i mean they are a little bit [ __ ] all
a little white trash though right
can i say that well i don't know maybe
just don't say that just don't say that
because
they're not really necessary you know
but aren't they all a little white trash
i don't know
does somebody some guy making a good
living living in a nice suburb
is that what you consider white trash
like what is that
yeah white trash is just no why trash is
like in the trailer no
like i think you can be a rich white
trash
then what is it just white no heavens no
so what is white trash white trash is
we are voting to drop it and it's been
dropped
right ratified stop
i'm gonna have to figure out how to make
fun of these people
this region they will take control
tomorrow
and then i don't even know what all the
i'm talking about the fraud will show
that trump was someone saying if these
people are poor then i'm homeless
and then probably wait what is what
evidence do you have that this guy's
killing it in life
he's sitting in a car he's sitting in a
car okay
fair enough
[Music]
job with the with the storming of the
capital the other week there's all these
people
flew in from all over the country oh
because [ __ ] turning point usa and
all these idiots like paid a bunch of
money to fly
in well maybe some people but i know a
lot of of them yeah you're right no
you're
arrested flew on a private jet yeah
you're right scientology has got people
oh okay i'm just gonna accept the
criticism come on i'm not gonna fight it
just accept it i'm gonna accept the
criticism i'm gonna internalize it
this is constructive criticism in our
chat
susan hate thank you chad and we
appreciate it we love each other
and we listen of this country ulysses s
grant
thank you of course he was the 18th
president so trump will be the 19th
president
of the united states be the [ __ ] wait
unless he says
the last president according to this guy
so trump is going to be the 19th
president
did that number that one lost me big
time he's like so to summarize guys in
case you didn't that made it make sense
he goes
so this coast here and this coast here
there's lots of planes down here
and in short ulysses s grants was the 18
well that makes trump the 19th president
clearly i rest my case
this guy's q anon so yeah this guy this
guy breaks the stereotype i think
that i have in my mind hello america so
a lot of you have been asking me if i
saw donald
trump's farewell speech and yep i
watched it live
uh my wife looked at me she was like
don't cry i was like i'm not crying
you're crying in all seriousness i was
not crying
hello america oh that's it that's not
too bad i mean it's okay to be upset
that this guy lost
i'm not gonna make fun of him for that
if trump does nothing by tomorrow
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa there's
copyrighted music skip that one
what does she say here i'll she she's
saying that if uh if trump doesn't do
anything
she's gonna realize that it was all
[ __ ] she's gonna realize q
is fake i love this guy trailer trashes
into seoul
that's what i think too white trash is
not doesn't have anything to do with
wealth it's just like let me think of a
white like a
rich white trash person i hate to say it
i hate to say it i don't like it
from daniel i don't like what you're
doing here i i have somebody in mind i
don't know if it's the same person
you're thinking
trump is a prime example of rich trailer
trash well
yeah kind i mean yeah he definitely
became
more white trash because he was all
manhattanite but now he's like
mar-a-lago here that's like oh is that
what you just read
this chat comment i'm just gonna say it
and it doesn't mean i don't love the guy
but papa john is kind of a rich way oh
that's not who i was thinking at all
oh you're going against the family here
see i don't know if you're
kind of what are you thinking of i don't
know i was thinking a kid rock saying
that
kid rock is oh yeah kid rocks perfect
he's rich
i think you you're probably just kind of
like
you don't know what you're talking about
because you've never been in those areas
it's true i'm accepting the criticism
i'm eternalizing i'm learning i'm
growing as a human being
california and ignorant yes thank you
people saying joe exotic is another
example
okay god yeah yeah my mom's side the
family's kind of white trash
and i met kid rock so i feel like i'm
qualified
you met him how would you describe what
makes them white trash like
um let's see how can they not be they
like barbecues
um i like barbecues but they barbecue in
a certain way do you understand
yeah they like they like cook with
garbage
what right no i'm kidding they don't do
that they don't do that
they cook in a certain way you know
you need to go live for a month in uh
some middle i'd love nowhere and then
come back
when they find out i'm jewish they
probably [ __ ] throw me in a ditch
though
you're one of them jews i heard about
getting boys
[Applause]
you've seen borat when they scream and
throw the jew down the well and
everybody starts singing along oh
they're saying jake paul
jake paul is definitely white trash oh
for sure
you know ohio is the kingdom yeah
oh it's kind of hold on boy you ain't
one of them jews i heard about now
oh boys we got a jew down here i heard
about him down in
and i saw one of them in the movies
you're no
no i heard if i drink his blood
i'll get them jewish powers
um people are confused what's with abs
background
yeah i'm not i'm not i know i don't know
why you chose that background you want
to
explain
wait my background my ethnicity or no
oh what are you guys trying to say
seriously what are you guys trying to
say
you're a [ __ ] power ranger dude
what's going on zordon oh i know it's
throwback thursday guys
are you wearing like a green suit or
something yeah turn it off you got to
show
oh my god all right see let's see all
the holes you cut out
are you wearing a green jumpsuit all
right all right hold on
i'm going to right now whipping
something out
you guys can't laugh
you went all out huh wow
wouldn't you put up a curtain behind you
and [ __ ] yeah that's how i do content
court too it's uh
it's just i throw it over like the
little room divider that i
have pretty slick you cut a p hole too
right
i did i cut up people on the green
screen
oh nice well i mean yeah you can't be
taking on and off the whole green suit
it's crazy right yeah i don't know
well done sir i don't know about that
why you gotta you will tease that i mean
you gotta you know what i'm saying i
mean we do these these are long episodes
i like the pee hole
okay yeah and it only zips from the back
and i'm home alone so
see like i can't unzip it
okay okay
[Music]
very impressive i'd love i'd love to go
live in like you know the south it'd be
fun
i i want to experience different
cultures i think until you do that
you can't really talk like that i would
love to buy a trailer
and be the only guy with like ac
i'll get like an ace unit be like i
heard about that ac there why
is that ac
everyone gather in the trailer boy it's
cool in here when kovit's over
you and tricia should come to michigan
and you could spend time with my mom's
white trash family
and then with my dad's arab family you
guys will get the full experience get
all the experience the whole gambit
as they say
how do you cool air i it's cold in here
what kind of magic is this
so nate is saying can we stop letting
chat derail the show it is frustrating
to watch you need to be in control of
your show
in the group and talk about it before
live that's
i also thank you uh thank you nate
let's continue i mean i'm enjoying the
conversation though because
to be honest i maybe it may be
wrong the way i'm making fun of it so
i'm open to the criticism
so i wish you anything would ignore chat
really
i thought sometimes it's good oh let's
continue on let's let's take
now i'm taking that note to heart i
thought it was good but okay
we'll see maybe you should ignore that
maybe they're the ones you should be
ignoring
yeah you know what i'm saying but let's
continue with the q and stuff
i guess shouldn't have expected anything
else from this country
sorry you know this guy lives in a
trailer the military is a [ __ ]
weak ass country we can't even hardly
beat a little ragtag [ __ ] outfit like
[ __ ] afghanistan we was over there
for [ __ ]
i don't know 10 years ago we're over
there for 10 years in afghanistan we
should have just nuked that place
we couldn't even [ __ ] kill everybody
in that country by
and didn't accomplish nothing got our
asses handed to us
that's me for my trailer he's right
about that what
he's completely right about what he's
saying right there oh dan agrees
you know same way not what you said
about nuking them but
we got our ass kicked over there well
yeah you always get your ass kicked when
you go
and people are in [ __ ] caves and
don't care if they live or die
the same shouldn't happen in vietnam
it's like you can't [ __ ] be people
that
that are just like so you know what i
mean they're down to scrap bro
they're down to scrap like you could
never be back same with iran
mm-hmm this country's a [ __ ] joke and
the people and it's a joke
and donald trump is a [ __ ] [ __ ] that
there's a joke right with him
oh [ __ ] weak ass what are we gonna do
man well let's get just to be clear this
guy was super mega
until so they're upset he's upset yeah
yeah he's disillusioned
he's disillusioned well they should be i
mean trump lied to everyone hold on i
love maggots right about 30 years ago
they should have killed every [ __ ]
baby that was born
uh so did he dan do you agree with that
part or no
no i was specifically talking about u.s
military getting owned in
afghanistan yeah but so just to be clear
you don't agree that every baby
born do not agree do not condone that
part of his message
because that does make us kind of ideas
because they're nothing but
[ __ ] weak little this guy should be
president man
[ __ ] spineless [ __ ] trash
and ain't just the young ones these the
older [ __ ] a bunch of coward
[ __ ] too
nobody will stand up there will not be
one person
stand up and do a [ __ ] thing in this
country they'll sit back
and they'll take this [ __ ] i hope the
fbi is looking into this guy
this is the [ __ ] that pence and trump
and harris shove down
i guess shouldn't have stopped everybody
in this country is
trash now excuse me i gotta okay we got
here um a trailer girl
hannah i don't know why y'all hating on
people who live in trailers
lmao i live in a trailer and i'm
definitely not trailer trash just poor
lol
okay so that i mean i agree you know i'm
you're right
you're right you're right it's a
stereotype that i
shouldn't lean too hard on because you
know i love our fans to live in trailers
we don't even know what we're talking
about
which is part of my problem but i mean
you know it's like yeah
i agree we love our we love our trailer
dwellers
skippy lives in a trailer love peace and
love
it's january 19th i'm done hearing about
this 11 hour [ __ ]
nobody's been pardoned no receipts have
been dropped
obamacare did not get declassified
[Music]
unless
unless he takes over with military force
tonight okay it's crystal clear
that we've been grifted and not only
have we been grifted
thank you for saying that he was in on
this
[Music]
and my thinking behind all of it is
he was the way that these [ __ ] could
use
he was the way to gun confiscation
he identified any dissenters
[Music]
all of his rhetoric all of the [ __ ]
pushing and hold the line
all of that narrative he knew it would
amp us up yeah look at the six
that was clearly a trap yeah
it was it wasn't a trap for any other
reason
then to justify taking the second
amendment
it's already happening with the first
amendment right
i want you guys to think about this this
is one of the threats
there always needs to be a conspiracy
they they're starting to think that now
trump
purposely worked them all up into a
frenzy to storm the capital so that they
could then all be round up
and use it as an excuse to uh confiscate
guns
yeah second bet it's the right to bear
arms so they're always
they're always super paranoid everyone's
trying to take their guns somehow and so
now
that's the new conspiracy apparently not
that he was just using you to justify
his
ends stay in power yes it was just
using everyone you guys should be upset
but um no mark is scary you know trump
is such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] with
peace and love because
in minecraft because
he had so many opportunities to say q is
not real
but every time people ask him about q he
says i don't know
i just think they're great people
they're against pedophiles like he know
god damn well everything about q
he amped them up he used them and he he
made this
he made this situation way crazier than
it should have ever been
he kept pushing very special
very special we love you
[Music]
we love you and what's happened with
the capital this and how they're pushing
that narrative
if you're from the outside looking in
it would be a pretty good argument to
start confiscating guns
nobody even there wasn't even that many
guns there that wasn't even part of the
conversation yeah i've never even heard
anybody bring that up
surprisingly actually it wasn't even
well because the protesters didn't
bring they didn't really the only person
got shot was a protester yeah right
there was a huge gunfight maybe they're
smart enough to know that they can't
fully take over this country without
taking our guns
bro you really i don't understand this
argument a bunch of peop of
like private citizens with some handguns
is really uh
gonna fight the u.s military i just
don't i just find that
argument's so silly but okay and learn a
different wavelength
some people might ask well why the
charade all right shut up dude i'm bored
with your dumbass
please we thought that they did that i
don't know what yeah we gotta get on
clapper you guys seriously
this this one thread is all clapper um
there's
there's other links in the dock we don't
have to keep going so is it like a
thing uh yeah it's it's like um
like is like free speech yeah so free
speech now
is synonymous with uh uh white supremacy
yeah i mean unfortunately it's like
free speech all these platforms that
build themselves as free speech
platforms
it's just all they end up doing is
becoming refugees
i don't know where hate speech and free
speech draws the line yeah it's all very
complicated and it's probably not good
that twitter is the arbiter of
what is and isn't accessible i kind of
agree with that but yeah it's
unfortunate that all these
platforms that are free speech are just
full
with neo-nazis and lunatics like these
people
so yeah i'm really confused about how to
feel about
because on one hand you have this big
argument taking place right now it's
like
first freedom of speech you know
obviously twitter
and facebook and all these big and tick
tock and these big platforms
are private held companies so
traditionally it's like well they can do
whatever they want their private company
but on the other hand you cannot
you know discount the fact that these
are
the platforms in which people converse
today
so it's kind it's hard to sep it's hard
to
that argument becomes harder and harder
to make well the whole thing is part of
such a big conversation
like that we need people we need smart
people
who understand today's technology
someone who's not 80 billion years old
now
they have to start talking about this
stuff like the algorithm
is [ __ ] everyone's life up with
pushing like if you're into one
conspiracy it's going to push you a
million more
it's like it's all part of a bigger
conversation in my opinion
there's so much to be more there's going
to be a reckoning because then yeah then
you also have this thing 230
power all this social media stuff like
it's more powerful than anything else
right they have powers and they have all
these exceptions like if you're from new
york times
or a cable network or whatever if one of
your new
let's say uh sean hannity goes on fox
news and he says i want somebody to kill
the president tonight
well they're responsible for that
content they can't put that [ __ ] out
there
yet on twitter and facebook people say
what the [ __ ] they want because of this
clause 230 which says that these
publishing platforms are not responsible
for what users do
it's very complicated because on one
hand if you revoke that
it will absolutely destroy platforms
like even youtube because
how it's going to increase censorship
because if they're responsible for
what's on it they're going to
moderate like crazy they're going to
start deleting content left and right
so but but on the other hand i think it
just needs to be revisited because on
the other hand they do need to be
responsible for some of the [ __ ] on
their platform right
it's interesting though i it's so
unfortunate that everybody's so at each
other's throats right now because i feel
like
there is an opportunity right now for a
consensus
it feels like there are people on the
left and the right that feel like
it's completely [ __ ] that these
companies have so much power over
our lives i mean there's a leftist
argument for this
and now there's a conservative argument
for it too and
they're always talking about how like
when we can't get anything done we can't
agree it seems like this is a huge
social issue that people
actually do agree on that like facebook
and twitter are too powerful in our
society we need to do something about it
and it's just i i don't see any i'm
hearing
towards that i am hearing more people
talk about it right now so i
i agree with you this is the perfect
time to start addressing
our leaders are too [ __ ] old we need
like hopefully they don't understand it
at all and
and a lot of them are captured by these
companies because they the silicon
valley donates
billions of dollars to them so you know
they're not
really in a rush basically you know
what's this mean where it's like uh
the black guy and the white guy who are
jack from predator yeah from predator
yeah the right and the left hating big
tech in the middle
i think something's got to give of
course but
honestly it's like our politicians are
just too old to understand it it's true
cycle them out but um big tech is
definitely ruining society
there's no question about it
let's see what this guy thinks go
exactly as we thought they would
did they i don't know what you thought
or expected but
i i wanted to see
i wanted to see it happen on live tv i
wanted to see them go down
right you want them to because it's
surreal to think
that the election fraud and everything
that's going on is so blatantly obvious
and yet they're seemingly getting away
with it
right yeah it's just sad so let me let
me move on to some other stuff
because there's um former trump
supporter i like the meltdowns where
people realize they've been grifted
these are my favorite ones that i love
yeah oh this guy's
got some juicy lips or something he just
looks glam as [ __ ]
oh no good pardons just so you know we
pardon drug dealing rappers we pardoned
the democrat mega donor
nobody nobody good nobody good um
nobody anybody was holding out for um
nothing d-class
not not that i saw nothing good
declassified so
we're kind of like oh this is how it
ends
this is how it ends we're getting thrown
off online
discriminated against and
stand up for us now and any liberals who
are happy that i'm a little perturbed oh
no you're about to get it
yeah i'm happier because you're in the
crap hall too
because you should see biden's day one
day one agenda
day bye to america this guy should be
the press secretary
i'd love to see this guy just talking to
the press all day
it's awesome all the over access all the
it's over it's done bro we're screwed
what
[Laughter]
uh where's all the people here here's a
great awakening thank you this is what
i'm looking for
q anon lady has a great awakening we
love it
so who else is feeling just a little
silly just a little
like went too far down the rabbit hole
now i'm back out again
and if nothing happens on the 20th
how many of you are going to feel stupid
as hell i i can't do it anymore
and who the [ __ ] is cute who is it who
is this person because none of it has
come true
and uh i was just thinking
like what if this person knows that none
of this stuff is true and they're just
messing with people like getting inside
their heads
you know i do
have that's i i'm genuinely happy for
her yeah
yeah i'm happy for her it's not easy i'm
proud of her
you know these people are a victim in a
way
falling into a cult you're 100
you know and it destroys your life it's
hard to pull out because you get so
invested
you get you get um like cut
off from everyone else because you're
you're believing in crazy stuff so
well one of the people yeah i mean i i
feel bad for her but i'm really proud
that she
is able to be so self-reflective and
just you know
it's good um there's some people that
are like i lost my family i lost my job
i lost everything for this
there's a whole um there's a subreddit
um
called q anon casualties and it's just
for family members
oh no family members because it's not
really videos it's more text posts but
it's it's the family members of people
it's usually the kids
of parents that uh have completely lost
their mind because of this cute stuff
yeah there's tons of people like that
out there it's crazy
mega lady loses her mind on tick tock
so i'm gonna say it because it's
mind-boggling to me
but i remember when hillary lost and all
of her supporters had a meltdown and
they became the nastiest of the nasty
people that we could find on our social
media
but what's interesting to me now is that
now your man
is getting ready to be inaugurated and
you still
can't let your hate go you people it's
not about who's in the office
it's about who's in your heart get that
right and your life will get right
have a great day mega that's not that
bad i mean she's a little looney tune
but
it's a message of peace and unity and
love
seemed worse
oh this one's just [ __ ] true this
you see this please save us
i don't even see our american flag
anymore
bad is talking with some kind of crazy
flag
what's she talking about what kind of
crazy flag was he with
it was an american flag it was one of
them if you look
closely you could tell that it's the
gold fringe thing yeah the gold fringe
you could tell there was only
this one is so [ __ ] up this person
assistance yeah
um
come on what guys with peace and love
i'm not reading this
well i mean that is so this
is read that bottom part it actually it
is very relevant
that's ron watkins this is the guy that
runs uh eight
[ __ ] which is the uh spin-off of 8-chan
or whatever where where q posts
and honestly most likely either is cue
or
knows who they are because he's the
admin of the site that q posts
everything on
and he's throwing in the towel here
basically he's basically telling people
to move on we gave it our all
now we need to keep our chins up and go
back to our lives
we have now a new president sworn in and
it is our
responsibility as citizens to respect
the constitution regardless of whether
or not
we agree with the specific details of
who is sworn in
as we enter into the next administration
please remember all the friends and
happy memories we made along the way
is this just it's the friends we made
along the way i mean literally the
friends were made along the way
it's not the families and the lives
we've ruined it's the friends we made
along the way the ship pisses me off
because i mean on the surface this
sounds like a
decent message right but this guy is
this guy is responsible for this
for that for that lady that was crying
in the last video it's crazy yeah
so [ __ ] him yeah
here's something cute this is from oh
this is from what is this from the
donald.when no this is from the
greatawakening.win which is another
i need a dot win domain man where's my
dot window the dot win thing it's like
they're
it's all the subreddits get banned off
of reddit they they regroup
on this other platform so the great
awakening was like the main q
subreddit and it got banned a while back
oh
they spent four years calling me a
naziana racist
then they demanded my silence then they
demanded i conform to their beliefs
then they stole my vote now they want me
to quietly accept it for the sake of
unity little do they know the best is
yet to come
fbi please please please yeah this was
uh posted
just a few hours before the inauguration
really right up to the 11th hour they
thought that
it the military was about to swoop in
and arrest everybody
i love it
eric and his militiamen they're saying
we can see here's the show off their
preparations for the battles they're
ice cream i might the reflection of what
the
sign the neon sign yeah i noticed that
right before we started it's because
uh i think the black background actually
makes and the fact that it's different
better close my uh
my gauge yeah close the corn dude come
on
i'm sorry this is exactly no this is
this is the guy oh
talking about eric and his militiamate
tim
wanted to show off their preparedness
for the battles they're expecting you're
gonna love
uh them we got a problem it was a bit of
a game but one that ended up starting a
fire
oh bye we got a brush fired on our hands
it is comical or is easy to contain
[Laughter]
i thought there was more of people who
were like i lost everything
i guess not
you know i guess that's kind of expected
okay queuing on
well let's remember we must help our q
and on brothers
we must rehabilitate them we have to
bring truth back to the people
what we should do is we should we should
collect them all in one place some sort
of like camp
kind of situation and re-educate them oh
my god
stop it what we need to do is put first
of all we need to identify them so that
we can help them
we'll put a badge that says cue on their
arms right round them up so that we can
teach them what's really true
and you got to make sure they stay so
maybe like fences and sometimes i think
we need to euthanize them too
because well we should just end their
bloodline oh
man see that sounds good
in minecraft of course in minecraft i
have a whole concentration camp in
minecraft it's crazy
i rebuilt auschwitz in minecraft and
minecraft
stop stop
you know be crazy if you open a
minecraft and you're like look it's real
i made
auschwitz in minecraft that's probably
even worse if you did that
okay moving on to the next topic
is it that bad
[Laughter]
um no but seriously we
no okay
no it doesn't doesn't even look so good
lately like the hair
the jewels she's on point every
[ __ ] time it's like [ __ ]
thank you
i'm just trying a little harder you know
it's that's hot
i could try a little harder you know
what i mean i'm trying i'm trying to
like
do something with my hair because i was
i was always so frustrated with my hair
like i would wear it just natural but
that would be frustrating because it was
always freezy and
kind of look like a 12 year old that
never figured out how to look okay
damn why are you saying that just
somebody in the chat said minecraft but
spelled like minecraft
[Laughter]
avery tosi that's all jews thank you for
that
um oh by the way just want to thank
everyone who's becoming a member you
know that this last week
the little plug for our membership
program hit the join button
you get every episode the night before
it comes out so
that's pretty dope and
we were great this week boy you got it
all and then
yeah yeah okay you know what everyone's
saying both of
us are looking good i'm trying harder
i put gel in my hair this morning you
want to feel it actually it's pretty
light it feels natural
i look terrible and i'm i am fat i don't
look terrible
do you know what i do it every night
before before i get in the shower i
literally just stand in the mirror and
do this
i can i can confirm
that he does that it's not it's not
really sad it's just intriguing that
like
i have this mat like it's so much and
then it hangs over your gut and it's
just
it's so it's just it's crazy it looks
inhuman
he's eating fatty like look at all that
dude it's
crazy it's like a whole another organ or
some [ __ ]
oh you know what else shane does that i
always hated that i've never mentioned
his conspiracy videos are
literally [ __ ] horrific
this like he's literally causing people
to be cute you know when he came in our
podcast he was saying that he made a
video about
sandy hook conspiracies i was like dude
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you really
yes sandy hook one of the dads of
of one of the slain children was like
smiling or laughing before he went on
the microphone that's literally the alex
jones conspiracy and
i don't remember that but jesus and we
talked about it when he was on the show
it's not funny what did you someone said
something about a 300 donation i don't
know if i missed something
we're checking it out we're checking it
out okay okay
so uh you know i've gotten some you guys
want more beef
you know what kind of beef why goo
yeah it's pretty wagyu oh this actually
is why goo beef
hey one so the quartering you know he's
friend of the show we made a video about
him
content court
he's a dumbass he's such a [ __ ]
dumbass so he's giving a basement tour
and some people are asking about the
basement
yeah that is a
not a raspberry pie but whatever the
other one is i forget now
not what it says on there it's got all
the games burger time
that is a raspberry pi
that sounds weird it sounds like a weird
sexy
arcade that's a lot of gaming and stuff
yeah this is insane honestly
that's all in his basement that big buck
cutter on the end here running out of
room
heat in my basement running out of room
nba jam on this side i could probably
fit a six pod here
anyway i saw this was like oh cool and
then i quote tweeted him and i said
where's the drain european
as you know he famously during the live
stream peed in his basement and
said i just peed in my basement
because he was mad that his wife went
out to pizza without him so he got drunk
and peed in his basement
so i mean it's a legitimate question i
was like where's the drain
because like if the drain's like down
here or something like that he's
splashing everywhere
he's splashing all over his arcades all
over the ground
you know i mean like does he clean it up
is the urine splashed all over the place
like
um lots of legitimate questions
jeremy lost his [ __ ] mind of course
he did not like that
he like tweeted at me like 20 times in
response to that
so let's take a look at i didn't even
respond because i was like
do i read these from the back or down or
the top down
they all happen within like 10 minutes
so it doesn't matter yeah
someone's going off because this is
obviously not the first tweet he says
he responded to me and retweeted himself
i would say
nothing you can say will distract me
from just how far you have fallen ethan
i'm hey i'm trying to distract him from
the obvious bro
you are ill irrelevant you've been
exposed
as a sad self-conscious grifter
what does he mean self-conscious that
i'm insecure or something
no i think that you're like aware of the
fact that you're aggressive
may your pathetic dying podcast shout
out to everybody watching
have a parade of more interesting people
on it so you can pay the mortgage on
that mansion loser got him
well he's so bad in my basement i don't
i don't want to flex on you jeremy but
i have a bathroom in my basement
so i don't know if that's like a rich
flex or what but i pee in my basement
but it's in a [ __ ] toilet
and the doors closed so i don't know if
that's a hard flex or soft flex
[Music]
so funny man well he goes on he says
someone says who the hell even watches
h3 at this point shout out to everybody
watching
i'm sure keemstar does because he wants
to see how his kid is doing
um nice it's funny they hate each other
except when it's about
me or you then all of a sudden we love
each other yeah
it's like you and james charles
they came up with the most amazing joke
and not childrenistic at all
that kim starr um
had an affair how do i say politely i
had an affair with him so when he came
and did our podcast
apparently somehow when i was away him
and ela [ __ ] real quick
right but it's not really in him and
neil it's like he [ __ ] me
you know no you were willing oh yeah he
[ __ ] he
[ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah so easy
yeah because he argues like a [ __ ] 10
year old that's why dumbass
as you know keemstar has this
irresistible sex appeal that women
cannot resist yeah it's his raw animal
magnetism yeah yeah i wonder what he
would say to someone who's trying to
pick up like
garbage what do you think it's like to
have sex with kim cruz with that big-ass
beard
the real question is does he keep his
head on what's the real question
does he keep his head on during sex oh
his bald head
don't touch what happened i don't want
you to see my bald ass head
it's crazy how bald he is bro it's like
a it's like a
bowling ball bro a finely waxed bowling
ball
trying to imagine keemstar [ __ ] king
star with that cute i mean i'm fat i
know i'm fat but he's got a bigger gun
like the beard the bald head
in my head those thoughts i'm the
[ __ ] bad guys like if he's on top his
beard is like in your face like let's
say keemstar is on top
his beard goes like to here look at me
so it's like let me get something let me
get something i don't pretend to be a
good person
[Laughter]
you have to find a a beard analog okay
that like this is the length of his
beard it is very long maybe that's a bit
too long but you get the idea
so if he so you know you get pretty like
so here's the bot here's ela's body
no no no you can't no no you feel what
i'm saying
you can't you can't do that guard is in
the face stop it
that's romance baby i can i totally
understand why you weren't able to
resist that
right
and then he continues of course did you
get an uptick in traffic when he tweeted
at you
why be hung up about it
no his tweets remind me he even exists
anymore outside of selling clothes
for people who want to self-identify as
taking the short bus to school he is
irrelevant
39 likes by the way come on man
i'm so irrelevant that he tweeted 20
times about me when i just mentioned
him briefly also your wife
without me i know it's so sad i'm sorry
jeremy i really do feel bad about
that i understand why you're so angry i
mean
that's just not okay i'll tell you what
either if you ever went out to pizza
without me
i don't know if our marriage could
survive all over this basement i would
i would [ __ ] pee oh exactly thank you
dan i would [ __ ] down here man [ __ ] it i
would waffle stop
by the way being real
jeremy's probably [ __ ] on the drain and
stomped it down absolutely
just being real they call that a walk in
my basement
i just pooped in my basement
uh someone said why is he so obsessed
with you what a loser
sheathen oh yeah he called me sheathin
i'm a woman feminine you have a vagina
dude
you got a vagina dude
sheathin bro that's like straight up
fifth grade
come on even in fifth grade i don't
think i'd be offended by that
well in his world nothing's worse than a
woman anyway he said that's a good point
in his world that's the worst you can be
the worst thing you can be is a woman's
that's actually true right right i
wonder what it
what his basement smells like i think
you can you know
musty you ever been in a public bathroom
rusty it smells like a public bathroom
just just awful like it just smells like
a urine you know
there's no ventilation down there
there's no [ __ ] windows
he said he remember he said he
remembered when he had principles and
deeply envies me
i don't know when in time he thinks i
had principles
oh his first response was sorry shethan
i don't have any games for pathetic
sellouts maybe you can get some games
running in your bel air mansion he's
very upset about our house
she then is really just you do have
games running
i've been playing lots of games yeah
that's great
i'm deep undercover
[Laughter]
i don't have any games for pathetic
sellouts what games are for pathetic
sellouts by the way
um is there a specific game for that
that's a good question yeah one with a
female lead character
sorry i don't have tomb raider here
sheathing
right he probably hates the last of us
too
oh yeah uh he keeps going by the way
we're like 10
tweets deep now and remind you i only
said where's the pu training and didn't
engage them
at all anymore imagine being h32
production being entirely irrelevant in
the youtube community but desperately
holding on to pathetic grudges
seriously pay off your multi-million
dollar mansion asap because your channel
is dead homie cash out kid
what is our channel is bad by what
standards
exactly i mean i guess if he's talking
about like our
formerly main channel but i've been
doing this podcast now for like over
three years
yeah full-time pretty much you know
you guys should review bernie sanders
memes oh i love that man
like gotta tell you i'm already over it
people because it's just it's
too many they're they're paying homage
to your favorite to your guy
i i love bernie but yeah you know what
i'm really iconic
cash out guys wait let's cash out kid
the quartering said let's just please
guys he's very obsessed obsessed with
our house
he's been still like three times
yeah they seem to there's more oh yeah
what the [ __ ] this is weird dude someone
said not dog your channel is whack as
[ __ ] and you deserve to hear it
stop why is my mouse keep moving i don't
know uh oh
oh you think it'd say it out and make it
entertaining and they have more than one
oh this guy's defending me imagine
should i mine
imagine being an ethan kleinstein dude
is a joke and a cautionary tale in the
youtube community
he's the dsp of commentary 69 likes
nice poor dsp
uh i i i'm not super familiar that
he's was like i don't know whatever it
is i am him
i'm sorry who the [ __ ] is h3h3 a dude
who used to matter
and is so desperate for relevance he
will openly betray his values and depend
on
vapid iq black holes like trisha us
for headlines 49 likes okay
well jeremy this was a fun segment so i
can't say that i'm mad that you
flipped your [ __ ] i i do enjoy
well i wonder what videos he's been up
to lately because he's always up to some
weird show videos i saw somebody dunking
on him just last week that he
had more brie larson videos like it
hasn't stopped oh my god who's clicking
that [ __ ]
oh he broke a million congratulations
hey really
i'm proud congrats keep on that i
honestly
keep on that grind you could find
another channel that praises brie larson
as much as me i don't think there's
people who are prey i don't think
anyone's obsessed like you are like
there's no pro brie larson channels bro
i don't
know what to tell you youtube attacked
again his titles are just great
uh a dark day for youtube cnn demands
youtubers be deplatformed
netflix actor slanders me
white esports woman calls espor uh
what the [ __ ] is his thumbnail look at
the aquaman
and the twitter flying out of his brain
like what and god's name is going on
dude
attacking male gamers for profit
i mean these are all just in the past
two days this guy is an
epic [ __ ] poster
i just peed in my basement oh here's a
breed lars the one from five days ago
there you go yeah brie larson broke my
heart forever captain marvel too
um tim pool cut off by facebook i
haven't heard about that
it's probably not true it's probably
just clickbait
let's see if i can find another brie
larson one these thumbnails man
jesus jeff seth rogan destroyed by count
dankula i'm sure that's not true
i mean you know seth rogen is pretty
good on twitter i got to say he's
yeah dunk some people
um hey did you see his thing with ted
cruz yesterday
oh yeah ted cruz was like you wouldn't
know you hollywood elite you wouldn't
know
anything about hard-working union people
and seth rogen's like dude i'm in four
unions
also somebody said a great thing he's
like dude you literally voted to
disenfranchise
every voter in that city right [ __ ]
dumb
[ __ ] anyway unfortunately in the past
two weeks she's only made one brie
larson video it seems like oh
slacking i wonder if she knows about him
she's like oh yeah i've heard about i am
her biggest
fan biggest fan
um he's been pretty mellow lately to be
honest
i miss the general white outrage kind of
thing you know doing his thing just
grinding
yeah rise and grind baby
wake up pee in the basement sit in the
studio
you know how it is bro how are you
making money if you're only making one
brie
larson video a month anyway
um god bless
ian do you want to give a covet update
oh like with his flight with his tastes
and chat yeah
i mean i'm i'm pretty much recovered
back to now
your taste and smell is back it's like
seventy percent
probably not good eighty how's your
breathing yeah stuff
it's it's better i've been exercising
it's been all right that's good
nice yeah oh all in all what this
started uh december 1st
so probably about 30 35 days
to fully get over it wow you feel like
there's
any lasting damage or you feel like
you're making a full recovery
it's just the smell you know and the
taste that's the last thing
but my breathing has been fine now so
and the smell
test is so odd i've never heard of any
other illness that like it leads your
smell and taste
yeah it's bizarre it's trippy and it
lasts so long like my goodness that i'm
sure the virus is totally out of your
system right now
yeah it's really nothing you know i've
ever experienced before
similar very unique
you know um just kind of to
kind of to our own horn our butthole
candle you know gwyneth paltrow's vagina
candle reportedly exploded in somebody's
home
and i just want to tell you like our
butthole candle is
made safe how does that
non-explosive that's what i kind of
doubt i kind of have questions about the
story to be honest because it's
literally just a [ __ ] candle
you know yeah i think this lady's up to
some shenanigans
so anyway but but like this is just the
butthole candle is so
it's just such a beautiful product not
exploding
goes to chair we i don't even have any
left why am i trying to sell it
[ __ ] so she made us did you know she
made a second candle called smells like
my orgasm
oh no so we have to make a second one it
smells like my jizz oh
it smells like my jizz what if we could
actually get
jizz smoke i mean right it's horrible
you could though because there's like
plants that yeah
there's a specific tree that smells like
dried jizz and i bet i could just google
it and
people would know oh it's a willow tree
scented candle that actually smells like
dried jizz
i think we gotta do it
holy [ __ ] it's so it's way more
disgusting than
what do you guys think i think we should
do it smells like my jizz is more [ __ ]
up i feel like it's
pretty it's pretty nasty i mean but hers
is it smells like my orgasm that's
pretty gross
you know i love it ian ivy what's the
vote
uh i think maybe you should get a candle
that smells like you know
credence clearwater revival
should smell like you're running through
the jungle
this is so funny like i always get
reminded in moments like this how
like we are so on the same page all the
time like
people are in the chat are saying no ew
and to me that's a great idea i'm on
board
i i was immediately on board i'm not on
board
i'm actually not on board because it's
it's just
too gross like the butthole is like ha
ha smells like a party
to me but if you bring it back into it
too
yeah it's just i don't know but for some
reason the female orgasm is like
beautiful and holy and it's it's
empowering and
it doesn't smell like anything it's not
like jizz is like weird i see like a
dude
in a robe who's not wearing anything and
he's showing you his dick
and he's like [ __ ] all over your room
when you're away i'm out
that's that's what i imagine when i
candled it smells like jizz you know
also you don't want a candle that has
jizz in it because it kind of sounds
like that too
you want to burn a candle which isn't it
yellow no but i was like
making a nice uh moment here and you
crushed
it yeah it's true well i just you know
you're kind you're more sick than me
what can i say you're a deviant i
thought it was you twisted
you said you're so twisted
hold on i need to i had it's been a
while since
i want this for wiki feet so i need to
i need to do something to step up my
wiki feed game
so hang on it's just it's unique like
if like michael jordan was to say this
smells like me
i think people would buy it and ethan's
the mj of
the feet world so i feel like people
like it
yeah i like it i want to smell feet
because we get that what was cool about
the butthole one
is like we didn't just make it smell
like [ __ ] we were able to kind of like
craft the real like
okay guys butt crack smell here we go
number one wikifee
spread your spread your legs a little
bit to your feet or your face i want to
talk about the feet
there it is that's the shot
all right so that'll help that's going
to be good oh that's hot
i should do an update every episode so
that we can keep it
i'm afraid if we get i'm actually afraid
of this one this might
me too this might get you man it's too
on the nose you know
no we have to pay on i'm giving it up to
my [ __ ] favorite one
i'm scared you wrote that really well
ethan
really i thought i loved it [ __ ] one
year old
wait so i wonder if it's already up
ethan wicky feet ethan
it'll be up within like a minute or two
yeah i'm on there right now
let's see what they're still adding
weird stuff
who is going through all my videos and
adding look at how weird this photo is
this is so weird that it doesn't even
look like your leg
wait what that doesn't look like you
it's me i recognize the carpet that's
from our house in woodland hills
the apartment where again that's a weird
one that's super weird i mean what the
[ __ ] what is that
creeps and then here's one
damn these people are so weird
what it's almost certainly our fans yeah
but they're going
too deep for me oh then i want to talk
about feet
oh my god guys we need to get my rating
up there's
too many haters coming in here and
messing it up i'm down to 6.56
is not okay i mean if you think i have
the top rated feet then
oh there's a wicky feet candle collab
wikifeet candle collection
[Music]
that might be the answer yeah oh there's
a trolls beware
trolls beware the guide is being ex the
guild is being extra awesome wait what
does that mean what the [ __ ] does that
mean i'm not a troll how dare
anybody suggest that what does that mean
i don't know wait there's a thing on the
side guilt what is the guild
look at the sidebar on the left one of
the options is guild
there's a feat guild the guild is a way
to let members moderate the site's
comments section
oh oh no
it's just the comment section they can
approve or reject comments that's it
they have no control over the rating
system they wouldn't i'm scared i'm
scared
dude they're coming for us they're not
coming for us oh my god
guys look at the comment section i love
how we as a guild and community shut
down the troll comments this page is
just ridiculous with the trolls
under ethan's feet wait how do i choose
the bottom nice feed ethan there you go
no hate remember since 2018.
oh oh there get jeffrey and shane dawson
down bro can i just look at his photos
oh my god i didn't realize this guy was
doing feet finished stuff
that's like one of the jonas brothers i
love how we
as a guild and community have shut down
the troll comments
oh but he's saying there's too many
trolls on my page i agree with him
this is not a trolley this is not a
trolley page
yes there's people that are being rude
that they need to shut down and i agree
with them totally
interesting by the way
sexual comments are only allowed on
wikifeet x so everybody keep your head
keep it pg keep it pg yo
listen brah actually these feet aren't
bad at all i kind of like them a lot
they're very real
attainable and big not super big but the
right amount
the toes are especially nice they are
perfect what
wow the [ __ ] you see what i'm saying bro
sorry
are you shocked for some reason
i don't see how this is relevant though
can someone please make a page for corey
frunk and his brother
sorry funk this is my page dude can you
bring that
somewhere else where's
shout out to the guild i mean they're
doing good work how do i become a guild
member
you know everybody should try to become
one yeah we need you all you guys become
secret guild
recovery we need to infiltrate wikifeed
at the highest
level possible all right
um we got the ball dough
we've got did you really look at that
yeah so there's the ball dough which
is interesting new sex toy
where i guess i can't show the video
that's fine
i i can just describe it because it is
interesting
oh so you put your balls
in this do you want me to put this on
screen oh you didn't thank god because i
was like oh bro i can't show that
yeah don't show it actually what is it
so you put your balls in here
and then it turns it into some kind of
um penis i guess
so you can you can use your balls to
penetrate your partner
we there's no way we can show this i
mean it's not it just looks like a
bullet
it's like a big bullet shaped object you
slide your balls in and
then you're good to go
and it's open so that like the ball is
going you know
i know this is crazy but i had a
girlfriend once tell me
she wanted me to put her balls in her in
her
vagina i swear to god
how would you even do that she requested
it and i said i'm not sure i'll be able
to
and i didn't try because i thought it
would be too painful
oh my god but she requested it
and i just was like i don't think i am
up for that
our well i would have tried frankly
somebody
yeah what the [ __ ] is with this
reflection you guys are screwing me
[Laughter]
yeah so
do you guys want to say show it it's
after dark people are demanding just
yeah oh the ball doe
nah yeah i mean go to baldo dot [ __ ]
net or whatever it is baldo.gov
baldo.org what's the weirdest sex acts
you guys have done
go ahead dan you first
weirdest i i'm pretty vanilla freakiest
freakiest
i don't know you ever put a ball i've
never put i've never popped a ball
in a in a puss oh zach also offered to
give us a balder review he said he'd do
it yeah he said he don't want to do it
i'll buy that ball though right now who
are you going to review it with
i i don't know you got to find somebody
i i i guess that's a hard stuff
you can't just do that with anybody
right all right
well you think you could tap that your
ex the porn star for a little baldo
reveal
for the show zach anything for the show
sure interesting
zack what's the freakiest sex act you've
done uh
dude you know there's too many well give
me one
i mean i i guess eating a girl's ass
after a hike i mean
yeah that's pretty crazy that's hard
that's pretty freaky i still
yeah that one's good
ian i think girls like that though zach
that like you're willing to get
so free you're willing to embrace their
just their body like that of course yeah
i'm not i wouldn't do that but i can
understand they're like i want a guy who
will eat my ass out raw
and sweaty after a hike i mean that's
they appreciate it beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing this isn't really
a sex act but
probably the freakiest thing related to
all that
is i once slept with the girl who she
claimed she forgot
i don't know what the [ __ ] deal was
but she had a tampon in
yeah when we did it holy [ __ ] and then
at the end she realized like
the act of the sex had shoved it like
way up in there oh my god
and i retrieved it out for her you did
that
yeah were you where was it like was it
like a one-night stand or was it like a
relationship it was a relation it was a
relatively short relationship we went
out how deep did you go like wrist
did you like mister i mean i kind of to
get it out of there yeah did you use
lube or did you go
wrong uh she was pretty she was pretty
lubed up if you will
because it was like right after the act
so holy [ __ ]
yeah it's pretty wild i managed to like
get a hold of the
you know the little string or whatever
and
get it out of there wow you asked i mean
again that's not really like a sex act
but it's like the thing
is yeah yeah that's wow have you ever
had like a condom pop
off and it gets stuck no i mean i've had
a condom
break before and we had to in like high
school actually
we had to get our hands on uh some plan
b that was uh
that was a stressful uh day yeah i don't
know if i i think i told you guys a
story about the
when i lost my virginity the condom
broke
on the first i think you had mentioned
the worst time
yeah it was weird it was really weird
my cock's just so [ __ ] big
um i mean we've
oh i would need to give a shout out to
skippy because
he skippy wanted to express his thanks
to us in any way he could
and his the best idea he had
was to commission this guy to make a
pancake sculpture for us
so skip this is skippy's way of saying
thank you to us for all the support
skippy who's on cameo please support
skippy on cameo the guys are the best
birthday message anniversaries uh
funerals uh
bar mitzvahs bris is
anything to celebrate life itself skippy
on patreon anyway here's what he
prepared for us so
honestly i couldn't think of a better
way to thank somebody
it's not me it looks like a leprechaun
oh it's you okay
photos are up by the way
on wiki i mean
your photos are up on wiki by the way
i mean this is the honestly there's no
better way to pay homage to somebody
this is me
are you supposed to eat them like why
pancake
i don't know it's just cool it's just a
real
so i i talked to him uh brief
back and forth and the pack i guess no
no
skippy okay and i guess his friend rudy
commissioned this guy to make him a
skippy pancake
and then i guess rudy paid for these
pancakes as well
yeah yeah and it was 75 bucks
for the three of them look at
even doing the logo so it's not the old
logo but
this guy make a living doing this it was
kind of odd
it's a very specific skill
but uh i haven't seen this one yet but
i've seen others that he does it's
[ __ ] good
it looks like a fun activity he does it
backwards which is really impressive
i got to say that's pretty good for
pancake art right there
you know kind of wanted oh it's just me
and you i thought he was gonna i thought
he said he was gonna do one of you guys
hmm oh what a [ __ ] rip-off wow
[ __ ] thank you skippy it means the world
to me
are you gonna send me the pancakes or i
just have the video
i wanna know who ate those pancakes
so shout out what a legend skippy
skippy's friends shout out 75 bucks for
those can't say it was money well spent
but i appreciate it
that's cool 75 bucks for a plate of
pancakes
it's a lot of money but i know that's
what i'm saying
but it was cool it was cool skippy is
also a
100 percent coveted free nine four oh
skippy we love him we love him we love
him
what a guy check out wikipedia
how long we've been going a little over
two hours
because i have the um soho karen which
i've been wanting to talk about
oh yeah oh karen oh
report duplicated no
oh there are two oh there are yes sorry
i'm gonna be i'm part of the guild i
don't wanna [ __ ] about my
nice come on who could argue with that
number one on work your feet
i'm worried those are good looking feet
look how nice those are
i've been doing good work on the heel
trying to like shave it down and
lubricate it and stuff look at that
come on man come on this is [ __ ]
awesome this picture this is the one you
guys
whoever submitted can you remove this
one erase this photo
now it doesn't feel like ethan i feel
like someone else
i think this is one of my favorite
photos of us
like it's a really good fight you look
awesome
it's pretty good i'm really scared this
is going to get us
bopped by the guild man hey can you guys
print this frame it and then the next
one i'll be holding that photo
oh and show my feet again it says hi
wikifeed or something
i think i have nice feet we're not
hacking there's a lot of people who like
my feet
why are you i mean it's really fair
you know a b for example is g is gaming
the system and that's not okay
they should remove him i am i'm off
yeah it's obvious that you took him out
yeah he doesn't even have feet he's just
a [ __ ] floating head yes i am pissed
that's the mp that's so funny
so should we do soho karen what time is
it it's 2 30. i think we could do it
a little something for people for two
hours let's do it
let's go soho karen time but only if
ela we haven't had mexican in so long
what does ian think about that i know
ian can we get mexican
i'm sorry by the way i know you're just
trying to be helpful
i think it's a good idea thank you
okay you know i i have so much trouble
with you
because like whatever we get you're just
not happy we get italian you don't need
it we got mexican you don't need it
and what do you want from me it's not
like i'm happily
um enjoying not liking my food
right people want ian sex story ian i
know you got some weird [ __ ]
dude give me one give me something toss
me a bone
oh dude
dude toss me a bone here ian if you want
a bone
you want a whole bone yes
i'll tell you what
[Music]
when it happens it's going to be so
freaky
when it does eventually at some point
after
[Music]
he's very pure marriage you're saying
you're a virgin
after marriage but no the bones will be
tossed my friend
so you're saying once you get married
you have freaky sex and then share with
us
yeah but until then it's pure vanilla
vanilla baby
baby briars
briars is good though briars are dryers
so ethan if we're getting mexican food
what are you going to order that's the
question oh
uh asada french fries with a double
extra dog [ __ ]
i don't know i'll try to get something
medium good
maybe i'm good like like halfway to
healthy not the asada fries
like what a burrito maybe
i feel like i'm entitled to eat like a
monster you eat one meal the day and
then i
slam 300 calories at night
all right
okay keep eating fatty ab do you have
any weird sex stories i mean i gotta ask
have you eaten any stress sweaty ass i
know you're married but well
um so what not really no
he doesn't have genitals right he's just
a [ __ ] [ __ ] head
you you well you're not like strict you
had sex before marriage i'm assuming
yes yeah i i don't know probably the
craziest thing is probably
not that crazy i guess but threesome
which my wife's
oh you had a threesome
yeah we're talking whoa when did that
happen
uh the first time i was 19 i
it happened twice once when i was 19 and
once when i was like 22.
yeah you did it twice yeah
does elena know that yeah yeah lena
found out this summer actually my best
friend
no she wasn't mad surprisingly i kind of
always wanted to tell her just because
you did two threesomes and i'm assuming
was it like one guy one girl
yeah no no no yeah two girls in me two
girls in me no i won't do one guy one
girl no
not my style yo okay so tell us about
the three one
the first one well the first one like me
and my friend eric were talking to
these two girls and we were supposed to
go over our house one day and then he
didn't show up
and i was there alone and i feel like
such a douche telling the story i don't
know
i kind of was like bro you were praying
that i asked you
come on no it's kind of like
i don't know for what what am i trying
to i'm asking i'll
beg okay but yeah no i i wasn't sure if
my friend would get mad because he
wasn't dating this girl they were just
kind of talking
so i went to the bathroom and i called
him he's like are you serious he's like
if that was me it'd already be in there
and uh yeah whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you
yada yada a lot
you're in the bathroom what led up to
that what happened
how did you how do you approach the
subject of having a threesome
did you bring it up it's so embarrassing
no i didn't bring it up no
tell me i was having
some trouble fake success getting a
erection
and then uh the other girl was like oh
if i would if that was
me i wouldn't have any trouble i was
like oh
and it just went from there i guess what
that's like straight out of a porn dude
yeah so let me let me get this straight
you're talking to them about how you're
having trouble getting it up
no we so me and one girl the girl i was
talking to left the room
and then we came back and the other girl
was like well that was kind of fast
you guys so okay okay hold on you guys
went in the other room with one of the
girls
yeah you couldn't get it up right you
came out you're like oh it was fast i
couldn't get it up and she's like well
she's she said that she said that oh he
was having trouble
and then her girlfriend was like oh if
that was me i wouldn't he wouldn't be
having trouble and then it kind of
went from there and so you when it's
back into the room with the two of them
and were you able to get it up was the
big question
yes but i i will admit that i did not
last long
it's awesome
yeah the story sounds a lot cooler than
it actually was i don't think so
you were 19 like were they also 19
yeah they went to high school with me so
not so crazy
no girl ever asked me to [ __ ] have a
threesome
i have to beg women to sleep with me
that's crazy it's not as fun as it looks
in this trust me bro
it's not like the movies no dude you
literally
what you said you [ __ ] in like five
seconds that's what i'm saying it's not
fun
but were you like really nervous uh
a little bit yeah and excited and
and did you go for round two did you try
to go back in or was it just one one and
one
with with one of them those around two
that was both
wow yoko yeah that's awesome maybe
what did lina say when she found out
about it
so what she said was weird at first but
she said no it doesn't bother her
nothing bothers liam she's also trying
to figure out yeah
i'm still trying to figure out what will
bother her she's [ __ ] awesome
and then you had another threesome tell
me about that when was that when did
that happen
uh this was when i had my own house and
like in my hometown like me and my
cousin were the first
people like have our own place all the
parties were at our house and
yeah i don't know a bunch of my
co-workers came over one day and
we were hanging out in the garage one
thing led to another no no no no
he's hanging out in the garage tell me
about how the conversation started
who's there let's get into the details
it's it's embarrassing and people don't
want to hear this do people want to i
don't think
i think people want to hear it come on
well um it was like 5am it was getting
late and then some people
were like oh we should go get food
people that were left and they left and
then
two girls stayed behind huh and yeah how
did you know them
who were the two girls that were you
folk yeah go ahead co-workers
co-workers ooh co-workers from the
restaurant you would still see them
afterwards
yeah and when they wear it afterwards
no really interesting did you do it more
than once with them did you ever meet
back up with them
um no huh
and were you able to get it up that time
yes excellent
and is that where you met your wife the
same restaurant yes sir
wow you [ __ ] everybody that's why yeah
everyone
yeah they're like there's no way they
didn't think me and we're gonna be
something serious because
yeah cause you [ __ ] everybody in the
restaurant talk to me baby
so i'm just curious how does this how do
you initiate a threesome was it that's
the thing
the people at home want to know just
give us
i never initiate that's the thing like
even like i'll never be like the one to
really ask a girl like
i what did they say to you
well it started with this i sound like
such a [ __ ] douche
it started with like a kiss in the
garage okay one of the girls
too can i hide my whole face actually
sure i love how you're just a floating
head
[Laughter]
but uh yeah i don't know because one of
the girls kissed you and then what
was the other one doing no well no at
first it was
a three white kiss in the garage it
feels like a plate wow
yeah god [ __ ] me my life is not so
different than yours
that's why the weekend's my favorite
artist that was the weekend was uh
was trending during those the weekend is
like the opposite of cl of clarence
clearwater whatever the [ __ ]
oh perfection he's like you that's like
the threesome
good things happen when the weekend's on
dude this is why people are black-pilled
because there's people like abe out
there that just [ __ ]
change out in their garage and have
threesomes and there's people like
you know the ultimate [ __ ] beta
you're the reason why people are black
pill baby i hope you know that okay
i don't say and did lena know the girls
that you had the threesome with
she knew one of them the other one i
think left before elena started working
there
well that's crazy dude
who knew that i didn't expect abe to
come with the most interesting story
totally no lena was friends with a bunch
of the girls we worked with
daddy
that's good awesome
jack you've had a threesome uh yes
of course what the [ __ ] who are these
people in these lives
tell me about that how many have just
once or more more than once
it was it was one time and it was
it was a devil's three-way what does
that mean
uh two dudes yeah oh no
no no like i can never do that anything
like that
and everything i mean he's my best
friend in the whole world
really and you guys are still best
friends oh yeah
really that's french the devil's
through something because you didn't
fire a friendship force why do you call
the devil shoot them because it's like a
spit roast or something
something like that you guys are going
to hell after oh because it's gay and
jesus states gays well there was no
touch in the
of the guy you know
you know we just couldn't stop laughing
the whole time
because like it was just we it was just
awkward and
we just couldn't stop laughing the whole
time bro
so i mean it's my
so did you look at his you must have
looked at his dick fully erect
does he have a nice one
[Laughter]
did your best friend have a good one did
you guys look congratulate each other
on your dick because high five yeah
full tower um uh
sure let's go with that it's nice yeah
sure god you guys are interesting man
this one this was years i mean this was
years ago my parents were years ago
you're not that old i know well
you're like 19. i was like i was 19.
yeah
and parents were out of town and uh
i don't think i even knew what a
threesome was you didn't even know that
was possible
it's so funny um
yeah i mean i've yeah
it was just it was funny it was awkward
i wouldn't say there was anything like
it was and then it was like an old
friend that was like did you guys
finish no no okay interesting
yeah but um yeah is it
is it even a threesome if you don't
finish
yeah i'm kidding
sorry i'm i mean i've you know it just
it just happened
wow this is very [ __ ] interesting
stuff guys
hey shredder you want to come up
shredder have you ever threesome hey i
need to check my phone
excuse me
make sure to make sure my in-laws aren't
watching
what the [ __ ] did you do
come here dan have you ever been in a
freeway
what going three ways
i can't believe what i'm hearing oh if
dan says it'll make me feel a lot better
how does that happen a gentleman doesn't
kiss and tell but oh shut up
who was it that's just so wild you
already said you're basically admitting
to it so just tell us
um was well i mean mine is a lot more
straightforward
i guess it's after we don't have too
dark there may there may have been
ecstasy involved
oh okay nice
nice damn wild night
it was a wild night was it with your ex
girlfriend because you guys were
together for a long time
no oh no
with either of them were you able to get
it up
uh because x i know yeah i i don't think
i don't think i did finish though
but it's hard on lucky yeah yeah
this is crazy bro i can't believe i'm
here i don't mind the i'm
blown shocked
this was two girls are a guy and a girl
two girls devil's roast no devil's roast
no
god's roast or i don't know what's the
difference so what do you call two girls
god's uh god's plan
god's plan god's plan
ian i i don't i feel like i don't even
ask because you won't even give me a
straight answer
you're just but he said he's waiting for
i'll give you a straight answer
because i think we all have here but
it's just you know me god in the holy
ghost
that's the only threesome i know
[Laughter]
and they were you able to get it up i
always get it up for god
god's plan ian brings balance to the
force
thank you ian godly you guys are full
surprise that's so crazy
is the are people in the chat as shocked
as we are or are we just like too
i don't know i feel like it's pretty
shocking that three of you guys have had
three sums
it's not i mean well i don't know
okay let's do a straw poll i want to
know how many people in the chat have
had three sums
strapple okay oh yeah yeah
one sec [ __ ]
women run away from me you guys have
been begging you for threesome total
life
was yours after age three there's
nothing
interesting nothing ever happened
interesting
you know how much work it takes to get a
woman in bed with me
let alone two
all right i want to know secret is you
don't talent you don't you don't
tell anyone that's where guys go wrong
they always brag
you don't go on the bench anything about
anyone you don't go on a podcast
send me the link it's all ancient
history you better you gotta tell us
this is what afterday is all about okay
guys have you ever had a threesome well
i'm gonna answer
no
20 that seems about right yeah i mean
it's not but
three i guess three of
i mean i've jerked off with both hands
does that count
that's about the most interesting sexual
encounter i've had look at the one
comment
wait i'm just a [ __ ] virgin i didn't
know you could leave comments that's
hilarious
shout out to send her up
stand her up wow
do threesomes of three women count of
course it does oh hell yeah
are you [ __ ] there
god's plan
blown away do you guys think about that
when you jerk off now like you think
back on the good days
i thought i had a problem before i met
lena what was it
no just me my girlfriend just messaged
me
oh [ __ ] but it's dance girl but i think
she knew about that
what did she say she just said
threesomes
[Laughter]
what i'm huh is because if i say
anything
lena's working right now so lena's not
going to text me because
her boss i can't she can talk to you i
don't care she can [ __ ]
any time she wants i'm not the i know
but she's always trying she's always
trying to be miss perfect
she is my spare fact yeah she's the best
yeah
brother howdy duty howdy doody time
you in cobra soho karen or whatever
well whatever her name was i'm actually
speaking so karen pulling her up right
now
this is so so karen
man this girl this whole story of this
girl is wild so
soho karen first of all it started with
one viral video
of her accusing a young black boy of
stealing her phone
and the reason i mention his black he's
black is because everybody
kind of assumed it was racist because
she's in a room full
of store full of people she points out
this
young black boy who's like 14 years old
lunges and grabs him
and he didn't have the phone she left it
on the counter or and she left it in a
taxi or something
and i'll play you the video but as you
learn more of this woman she has like a
whole hit
there's like several viral videos so she
is kind of like the ultimate karen in
that way so she has all these separate
incidents
but here let's go
i'm sorry better get on
we have what you you see we see two
black people no i'm not letting him walk
away with my phone
you know nobody stole it it's literally
her fault
the taxi came right back and returned
the phone here it is from another angle
new video from the nypd shows that woman
tackling that 14 year old boy
accused of stealing her cell phone later
she's seen falling over
it's that surveillance video from the
arlo hotel keon harold's parents say
shows the hotel management mishandled
the incident
after the hotel helped the lady retrieve
her phone
they did not have a security we need
tears and press conferences i don't know
i don't know it just it seems like a lot
of much to do about not that much
i mean it might and i'm not and i'm not
pro so who cares this is just my snap
judgment
no it might have been traumatizing for
the kid yeah i agree but like you have
like a hundred people here with the mic
and [ __ ]
pretty ask her to wait for the police
why is he crying
which they said they called no i'm not
letting him walk away with my phone
this is the video that initially went
viral the hotel apologized
but acknowledges they could have done
more the woman still not charged with a
crime
but nypd sources say they know who she
is
and in fact cnn says they got her on the
phone where she claims
she was injured we got like live music
and [ __ ]
but outside city hall wednesday jazz
music i think it's not that serious but
okay
jesse jackson's involved like godzilla
demand
full prosecution coming up well yours is
buffering still
right it is buffering now but the
internet look at [ __ ]
look at abs background like what the
[ __ ] i mean we're on zoom
we're all talking so i mean the
internet's obviously working
uh youtube says excellent connection i
mean oh i think it's back
i think it's back it's back okay good
we'll do it live we'll do it live [ __ ]
it
[ __ ] it don't do
it was the [ __ ] if we were joking it was
the uh clear clear
clearance clear clearance clear water
thank god you can't say it
clarence clearwater
creedence clearwater curse there you go
it's the cree
the curse of credence baby take that
[ __ ] background on
zack you can't be serious please i beg
you maybe
bro what's what scare never mind
all right we're back i don't know if you
guys missed everything we were talking
about with the soho karen i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on
but um did you guys see the video we
were with her tackling and the mayor and
everything
did you guys see that i think it just
went out i think it went out like as
that video so here i'll i'll pull it up
what's happening
i was just joking that like it just
seems like the nypd show
just like knowledge is a bit of an
overrated i don't know but they've got
like live music
and jesse jackson is there commenting
and the reference reminds me of like a
scene at a seinfeld where george
like this is something that would happen
to george costanza where like he
mistakenly
thinks someone stole his phone and then
the mayor is involved and jesse
jackson's involved and there's a whole
parade
about george costanza's feeling criminal
charges
we demand full prosecution
we demand if this woman is saying she
was assaulted
put her in the grand jury how many
people end up in prison forever how many
people yeah
because of because of mistaken identity
quote
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh and then mayor de blasio's being like
talk i mean it's quite the mirror put on
a [ __ ] statement
anyway so there's more this is where it
gets interesting because at that point
i'm like ah
it seems a little overblown but then
okay [ __ ] gayle king
why is there so much entering over this
girl gail king
interviews her
on cbs this morning like guys holy
the woman caught on camera physically
there's a whole six minute interview but
there was one specific moment um
that stands out there should be some
context to your actions that day
okay so basically
i'm a 22 year old girl i am i i don't
that i
racism uh is
how is one girl accusing
a guy about a phone
a crime what there should be some
context
wait that's it where's the point where
she shuts her that's not the only good
moment
guys she's not even apologizing
no this thing is a mate here let me see
this morning we are sharing more of our
oh god there's two parts guys why don't
you just make a full 12-part documentary
about this at this point
with scenes and reenactment and maps of
the
floor plan and [ __ ] it's not enough
one part is just not enough you might
remember this video
mia poncetto approached 14.
because in my mind anybody exiting is
probably the one that
might be the one that is trying to steal
my phone i admit
yes i could have approached the
situation differently or maybe not
yelled at
me like that and made him feel you know
maybe some sort of
uh inferior way making him feel as if i
was like
hurting his feelings because that's not
my intention i consider myself to be
super sweet i really never
ever meant for it to like hurt him or
his father are you saying that you were
stopping
everybody in the lobby asking them about
your phone is that what you're saying
the kid could be played by cuba you
didn't junior
digitally made younger everyone just the
just the people that in the meantime
while the hotel manager was
checking the footage i just wanted to do
my part yeah because you played padded
main star wars i forgot
as best as i could you just described
yourself as super sweet i know you've
seen the video when you look at the
video
the reaction seems very extreme it
doesn't seem like
she's unstable she's obviously like if
you were alone in new york
and you know you're going to spend time
with your family during the holidays
and you lose the one thing that gets
stolen from you that has all the access
to the only way that you're able to get
back home
i just don't think i would randomly
attack people is what i'm saying there's
a nominee
you can't handle it better but i just
don't think i would
randomly attack people in the manner in
which you did what do you think when you
look at that video
you're standing there in your leggings
and your flip-flops and it looks like
you're just going
nuts for lack of a better word yeah
she's unstable clearly
i don't feel that that is who i am as a
person i don't feel like this one
mistake does define me but
i do sincerely from the bottom of my
heart apologize that if i made
the sun feel as if i assaulted him or if
i hurt his feelings or
the father's feelings i don't believe
one mistake defines anybody
but i i think when i look at that
particular video
you're you did more than just accuse him
the video seems to show that you
physically attacked this young boy you
do see that too
right at the end of the day the dad did
end up like slamming me to the ground
and
uh pulling my hair throwing me and
dragging me across the ground so what
did it happen
i will dragged her across by the hair
but but i think you know
the video we saw it looked like you had
just attacked his son
yeah the footage shows me attacking his
son
of attacking him okay
i apologize can we move on i know you're
saying i don't need to i just want to
apologize
but i do think that there should be some
context
to your actions that day okay so
basically i am a 22 year old girl
i am i i don't i racism
you're right yeah that proves she's
racist she did it
jesse jackson walk out here
that's not the problem you have to at
least understand your actions that day
you seem to have attacked this little
boy this young boy this
his teenager you seem to have attacked
this teenager about the phone
and then it turned out he didn't even
have your phone
that's the thing i mean you're saying
look i'm 22 years old you're 22 years
old but you are old enough to know
better
so i will say you're 22. i can't kill it
enough
that's what i love that's what i was
looking for all right gail enough
you know what talk to the hand [ __ ]
hey you seem to have attacked this
little boy this young boy this
yes teenager you seem to have attacked
this teenager about the phone
and then it turned out he didn't even
have your phone
that's the thing i mean you're you're
you're saying look i'm 22 years old
you're 22 years old but you are old
enough to know better
so i will say you're 22. i can't enough
that hand gesture was like the ultimate
oh my god next time we have a fight ela
all right enough enough
i don't even know how to do that hand
gesture that condescending enough
is it like fall down or is it just the
wrist fold down
enough yeah it was just the wrist let me
see
she's here so you're 22 years old but
you are old enough to know better
so i will say you're 22. enough oh
it's so she lo she didn't move her wrist
enough yeah it's like straight
yeah well don't have hitler back there
dan dan's back here highland hitler
enough you got to bend your elbow
otherwise it looks suspicious what
you're doing
the hotel did have my phone the hotel
did end up having my phone
i didn't get my belongings
what is she trying to say with that i
don't like it i think
people said it was a merch for a podcast
of like daddy
call me daddy or something huh
there's some podcasts with two girl
female hosts oh
i don't think he's on it but it might be
a bar stool sports podcast yeah i think
it is
yeah all her daddy yeah yeah it is
really of course she's so anyway this is
just the first incident right
so now this isn't the first time that
maya has been problematic
in fact soho karen threw a tantrum
during a dui
arrest last year nice and it's on tnt
yeah so the pattern of behavior comes
together here
um this is yeah yeah
oh my god i love the math
how how are you how are you holding up
do you have any
this woman tmz is following her around
now
like i don't we think this is just a
little overblown
i don't know because the story is really
upsetting
and it's like all right there on video
so i can understand
tmz the mayor is involved
new york city mayor
like that guy doesn't have better [ __ ]
to do it's better him make a statement
about it than someone like trump say
um people are fine on both sides you
know
at least that's good so if trump came
out was like she's a very special woman
yeah we love her
regret about what happened the other day
following her by the way you need she's
a celebrity you need the mask right like
the facial yeah
[Applause]
have a very good day take care of you
look do you uh are you worried you know
the police are looking for you
the police are listening okay the police
are looking for in tmz found her yeah
i love that somebody gotta [ __ ] tmz up
with police enforcement
law enforcement learned about uh the cia
is currently tracking you the fbi has
why did you
do it you know
he's young i mean do you do you have any
regrets i'm actually 22. so
i don't know puerto rican so thank you
i'll see you okay does that justify what
you did
i'm actually 22 so
[Applause]
she keeps trying to play the card of
like i'm just a kid wait this link
doesn't have the dui footage i don't
think
yeah it's under there's a video of
instagram where
oh and the document greg is saying this
is hysterical news story it's not news
it's manufactured hysteria
definitely on the other hand i mean it's
a viral video which i understand the
virality of it but
it's time to hold people accountable for
jumping to accuse people of color with
no basis
that's fine i agree but like the mayor
not overblown black people get killed
for no reason this could have easily
went there true um okay i can understand
yeah if the police
the police can yeah i mean look you have
like that woman
in central park who was like there's a
black man harassing me
right and then like yeah the police can
should come and arrest people for no
[ __ ] reason unlock them off for life
so yeah i get that
anyway here's the incident of her being
arrested during a dui
cop said her blood alcohol level was .14
almost
twice the legal limit she was already on
probation for another dui i mean how the
[ __ ] do you get a dui in euro
and like isn't one dui like you're out
i don't know what the [ __ ] so this is
our second dui
well there's probably a period where you
can regain it now
she had a first dui in may and this took
place in october
i don't know and in that dmz
tmz video she was getting in her [ __ ]
car yeah so what the hell is going on so
okay
give me your warrant don't touch me
please and thank you you're getting the
full
monkey
[Music]
ma'am he's telling you more than five
times now you should listen please
listen
to me
i think this is pretty much i think we
can i we should all be able to agree
that this is white privilege
this woman got two duis resisted arrest
still somehow was driving and then
and she's still out doing her thing
without any concern and then that phone
incident
yeah i mean she kind of attacked that
kid
well she did she for sure dead
members that are killing people and now
she's getting to be a celebrity
like following her yeah i mean
i guess i i've always disagreed with the
ever i
the the mantra that there's no such
thing as bad publicity i don't i
disagree with that
you know well i think there are sick
enough people that will
find her appealing somehow and will
follow her
you know like she could gain a following
for the wrong reasons
do you think she's a icon so wait
there's more there's more like how
murderers can have groupies you know
like
it's like that so ela there's more
um her her and her rican by the way
she's not
white they're saying in the chat oh you
know what they say there's uh there's
this phrase
passive white passable you ever heard
that dan
it's a real thing just type there as you
said she's uh
white passing yeah so that means that
people perceive her as white
right you know because
you can be like oh i'm puerto rican but
if you look people you know
it makes sense yeah i've got that a lot
growing up because i don't look arab
yeah you get that white pass bro you
have that white privilege
and here madeline said i think a big
issue is how she acted afterwards
so entitled true no normal person would
do that i agree she's so upsetting
like she doesn't even apologize i'm not
disagree i think the whole thing is
amazing that's what i'm here i just
think it's funny that
the [ __ ] mayor got involved
i think it's good i would want my mayor
to say something rather than not say
something
and all of new york city there's a lot
of [ __ ] that happens every day there
people get murdered but this is a
sensitive topic
right what's that we're coming off of a
year that george floyd was murder you
know
right murdered oh and speaking of which
what was that dj that did the tribute to
george floyd
uh dave guetta
you say his last name david guetta
someone like me the video of him doing
the tribute
that's the way it's the video speaking
of we have to honor joyce
george floyd's family since we talked
about it
all you guys really had threesomes huh
that's bugging you huh
speaking of george floyd's family we
really need to
we we need to wash the taste of out of
our mouth
and pay homage
[Music]
so this is dave judah i don't know
he's doing it he's just gonna get it i
always thought you said guetta but maybe
that's in it
[Music]
united at home
the world is going through difficult
times and it sounds like a bomb in
america too actually
stop so last night
i knew we were gonna do this and i
made a special record so this record
is in honor of george
floyd and i really hope we can see more
unity and more peace when
already things are so difficult right
so very nice to his family shout out to
his family let's go
shout out
is this the real one isn't the deed
though
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
mlk i still have a dream
it is a dream deeply rooted in the
american
[Music]
i love it it's rewind time bro there's a
version where it goes d die did
[Laughter]
yeah can we just watch that shout out to
his family
that drop yeah
i have a dream
people will party and we will get
through these start times with dick
shout out to his family i love that
i love that shout out to his family
because the shout out's like a happy
thing i know
shout out to his family now that's how
you honor
racism has been cured yeah racism is
cancelled
that's how you care so anyway back to
soho karen
her and her mom were charged for another
crime last year involving being drunk in
public
and not on top of the dui yeah a
separate incident bro
she needs to be locked up somewhere and
then there's another incident cops
spotted her in malibu driving
erratically and pulled her over and
there's a video of that incident
oh my god yeah this woman is a menace to
society
where's your word oh this is the video
we already saw that's the malibu one
yeah
she was taken to jail booked for a dui
received three years of obey probation
30 hours of community service she's
gotten another dui since then and she's
still driving how the [ __ ]
does that make any sense oh this is all
[ __ ] i've seen
bria last year
she and her mom were at the pennsylvania
hotel and
bay hills where employees asked them in
vain to leave after they appeared
inebriated
lee she has an alcohol problem the cops
came
and her and her mom allegedly pushed and
kicked an officer
the mom was arrested for battering on
officer and being drunk in public
maya was arrested for being drunk in
public as well they pled not guilty and
have a hearing next month
epic jesus and then another i can't
believe there's another story
so dude this woman is a walking calamity
so she apparently wreaked havoc on a
vacant new york city apartment before
her notorious
wait here
so apparently she went in a trash some
hotel some vacant apartment
what
uh i thought there was a video of it was
allegedly wreaking havoc
on a new york vacant new york apartment
before her notorious hotel incident
as reported soho karen was charged
saturday in her attack on a 14 year old
oh they charged her
sources familiar with the apartment
incident tell tmz
that she entered the building by using a
fire extinguisher
she found to destroy the doorknob and
smashed her way and this woman is not
well oh my god yeah
we're told the tenant of the building
confronted her and she allegedly claimed
she rented the vacant unit through
airbnb
and locked her keys inside so she took a
a [ __ ]
fire extinguisher our sources say airbnb
isn't allowed to operate in that
building yeah that never stopped them
from renting anything
oh pretty amazing huh so caring people
wow guys she's only 22. go easy on there
yeah uh zach that's enough
that's enough well the fact that she was
drunk in public with the mom
kind of tells you you know yeah she's
brought into some weird
yeah and the mom was arrested for
attacking the cop yeah
so nice
shout out to george floyd's family
that might be my new favorite video oh
my god it's such a classic
we need unity shout out to his family
speaking of djs i don't i don't know
anything about the story i just saw you
guys talking about the other day but
what's the deal with
dj khaled and only fans yeah oh dj
khaled may the only fans with fat joe
but it's not nudes it's like a exclusive
fan club it's twenty dollars a month
let's see wait so it's
gonna just become basically another
platform like not necessarily
i kind of agree a lot of them of the
only fans models are saying
that these all these mainstream people
are ruining uh
only fans and i kind of agree at this
point
only fat
i didn't know if it was appropriate dj
khaled and fat joe wants
joint only fans account i mean guys get
a [ __ ] life
how about this if you want to make money
go make some music
i think that's a little bit not fair for
the people who are using it i mean god
help anyone that actually pays for this
though
well people will for the meme i think 20
bucks a month
i don't know that they'll keep it
probably just one time exactly you know
what to do
zack you inside there already i know
you're
no i couldn't find the link for it um
oh maybe they just sent out or
they said they announced it um
for twenty dollars a month so it sounds
like it's up
so like cardi b hasn't only fans that's
free
because you you pay for stuff in the dms
like
remember zach explained it's like
there's some have a subscription fee and
then sometimes there's like
so what do you pay for is it nudes like
what would anyone pay for that would be
worth it
i don't know everyone's different like
if it's usually
why are these celebrities so thirsty for
this extra money i mean what the [ __ ]
man you guys are
like do not need this someone explained
to me once
it's like a strip club like you're
paying for admission but if you want a
private dance you have to pay extra
okay but like what does cardi b do for
her private [ __ ] does she show titties
probably oh i'm not sure i don't think
so it's just like behind the scenes
stuff
yeah i i bet you it's not titties i mean
she's she's a little cerberus doesn't
show her titties anymore she's not a
porn star
newton model whatever tyga does he [ __ ]
do you see his dick or anything
nah
would you do a devil's throw with tyga
what if he was really hot what if it was
belle delphine would you do a devil's
three-way with tiger for that
for belle yeah nothing are you still
following love just found the only fans
oh for fat joe look at their url here
love found it thank you onlyfans.com dj
khaled and fat joe
guys i mean come on there's got to be
better ways to make money
welcome to the light the page for fans
to get exclusive motivational
and inspira guys we're here to jerk i'm
here to masturbate not to get motivated
and inspirational content will be
guiding fans to the light
while sharing uplifting insight was a
wife it's so inspiration if your goal is
to inspire and motivate me why the [ __ ]
are you charging me 20
a month shouldn't you be putting out in
the world when you guys are both so rich
you know what you mean
i don't know maybe dj khaled's uh
hurting all the musicians are hurting
this year they can't tour
that's how they make most of their money
yes i mean
and and this is kind of rock bottom in
my opinion
uh it's there's always cameo
apparently they only have 16 likes total
if he is it's probably super expensive
wait what does that mean
16 likes does that mean there's only 16
people that signed up for this
ap or zac uh no just on that one photo
this is their main page this is their
main page no no but if you see
like you see how all the photos are
there's one like one
yeah yeah yeah so it's like like i don't
think it's really popping i don't think
it's working
and no it has one like yeah
yeah who wants to see one like before
like two likes
you're gonna post this on instagram two
likes i think it's all dj khaled in fat
joe
this one has three likes one like
bro five likes on their announcement
post that's poppin
someone in the chat said i paid 40
dollars for a picture of a girl in her
bra and underwear you don't see what the
pic is ahead of time so it's a shot in
the dark
[Music]
roll the dice and they'll they'll phrase
it as like
you know naughty cure that's why
everyone was mad at bella
thorne because she delivered like a
basically an instagram pic
right yeah [ __ ] you have to be
really horny to pay for that
reminds me of like being in a hotel room
and it's like 50 bucks for the porn and
you're like
thank god you got to be really desperate
i did that one time i gotta shoot a new
[ __ ] by my parents
yeah oh my i never had the balls to do
it where my parents were there because
it's like
you went out what did you think was
gonna happen yeah
you can't control yourself you just you
know when you're horny
you say [ __ ] it i had to do it and then
you watch it for like two minutes and
you're like well that was worth 50
dollars
[Laughter]
oh use your imagination it's not the
same yeah we all
we all haven't had two threesomes maybe
yeah
to think back fondly on touche
danny's tired
um have you been following bel
delphine's only fan zach
uh yes i have is it still like all out
uh she's definitely posting more crude
content
more uncensored [ __ ] um
all right congratulations
um yeah it's great it's fantastic happy
the time of my life
happy for you excellent rico nasty i
don't know who the [ __ ] she is
swally why why are these people have
only fans i don't like it
ruby rose casanova
wherever the [ __ ] these people are
bump j 50 bucks
what's bump j up to for 50 bucks
hold on let me pull up over bump chase
account
he only has 23 posts 50 bucks a month
bro
one like come on man
four likes i don't think it's really
hitting
i don't know any of these people are
trina blue face
a boogie with the hoodie
uh fat joe and coward one like
spectacular the one like spectacular
cause who wants to spend 20 for that
[ __ ]
that's what the [ __ ] i'm wondering
christ and they probably lose interest
and just stop posting they don't even
say anything
okay i just think we're done you singing
the [ __ ]
hamster dance is that what that is yeah
i saw
a type the dj and the hamster didn't or
whatever
somebody just did a meme yeah it's funny
i liked it a lot
you guys got to see this
you want to order as i'm doing this you
want to get some mexicana
really we've gotten to that level of not
caring
i mean we're like three hours deep we
are actually
they're only the real fans at this hour
it's the same amount
[Laughter]
this is on the real one
yeah send me that i have it we got it
send it here boys
this is the real version somebody
actually convinced me on reddit that
this is the real version so
i guess i'm an idiot but
here we go this one's this goes out to
you and george floyd's family
so this is it it says dave gueta
ends racism this is the original video
it's not the original video it's just
amazing
is in honor of george
floyd and i really hope we can see more
unity and more peace when already things
are so difficult
the music's different so shout out to
his father
[Music]
that's the best anyway it's called dave
and
racism dude
you better find the original shout out
to his family
you better find the original i need to
know we watched the origins
yes he ends racism what are you talking
about
no we watched the original but this
one's not even that much crazier than
the original
it's just after the drop it's that
shout out to his family i love that
i'm gonna watch it again
[Music]
is so difficult
so shout out to his family
it's the [ __ ] best
it's definitely the dancing and smile
and everything
it's so [ __ ] funny
he's so happy
there's a whole there's a whole bunch of
these what is this shout out to his
family
so last night i knew we were gonna do
this
and i made a special record you know
he's like all right i have the show
booked
i can't cancel it because i'm gonna lose
out on like fifty thousand dollars i
need the money
so i need to do some tribute or
something
so this record is
in honor of george floyd
i really hope we can see more unity
and more peace right when already things
are so difficult
i wish saaho karen would have seen this
so shout out to his family
[Music]
so even though we faced
the original
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
meme ever bro
we should make our own and put something
at the end is
in honor of george floyd
and i really hope we can see more unity
and more peace
when already things are so difficult
[Music]
ah i love that [ __ ] man
and that's that eh that about sums that
one up
well guys what a hoot it's been what a
hauler it's been really
or who'd been hollering so we're not
here obviously we're not here tomorrow
because we did it on thursday instead of
friday
because eli has adopted appointment
tomorrow next week however
normal schedule i think we'll do four
episodes next week because we have to do
a regular podcast in addition right
is that the dream is that the design in
addition to what
in addition to that after dark and so it
would be frenemies
yeah oh we don't have a third one so it
would just be three
the frenemies normal episode after dark
right
right i think that's a good rhythm
fourteen four can be a lot
yeah it's gonna be a lot but like two
pre-recorded one live i like that that's
a good rhythm
yeah boy yeah boy
cool all right please use the classic
h3 outro music today somebody donated 50
to 50 dollars
the classic h3o do you have that zach
you better have that right
that's the original h3 thief from from
the
main channel yeah i think that's what
they mean yeah the original i have that
in my
repertoire here i don't have that either
just pull it from youtube
i'm going to go play dark souls 2 this
weekend i'm a
i love that i think that's my favorite
one so far i've been on this dark souls
kit because i never played them
so i beat demon souls on ps5 i beat dark
souls 1
now i'm on dark souls 2 and i'm crushing
it bro
i've been umari i'm proud of you
this song has a vibe like everything's
good when the song plays
you know like you say i beat catamara
either just texting right now
i'm sorry you're talking about video
games i'm out yeah
well anyway guys have a great weekend we
did it joe
you're gonna be the next president
we ended racism here today you know
we did it we're number one wiki feet
got the best candle in the game i've got
a bathroom in my basement
my life is [ __ ] made straight up
all right we'll see you guys on tuesday
with a brand new friend of me so uh
peace and love everybody all right see
y'all
then
[Music]
you